foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
the premier online speed chess
tournament a knockout filled with
tension drama quick tactics and shocking
moments
oh my gosh for the last seven years and
counting the best Blitz and bullet
players in the world have flocked to
chess.com to prove their worth at this
format
excitement Reigns every year with major
upsets and intense battles
year 12 invitees and four qualifiers
face off for the title dozens have tried
but only two have ever worn this Crown
Magnus makes it look easy
wins the speed test championship
[Music]
who will be this year's Blitz King in
time to find out
welcome to the 2023 speed Chess
Championship presented by coinbase
[Music]
the 2023 speed Chess Championship is
presented by coinbase it is back again
on this Monday International Master
Danny wrench alongside the Grand Master
Amman Hamilton I'm on Hamilton how are
you sir
hello Danny and uh hello everybody
Welcome to the show I am excited for
this one Danny because I just did a show
with Dania and I mean switching up the
commentary Duo to the one and only Danny
wrench I'm excited man yeah you have to
downgrade from the GM to the IM but you
know this relationship the fans who
maybe haven't seen this Duo before I
want you to know this relationship
between me and Amman it works I I think
you're gonna enjoy it today
I'm not gonna say I'm not gonna say
anything to contrary yeah well let's we
got so much to get into man we're gonna
have a blast let's just remind everybody
what match is in store it is Fabiana
carbuana an SCC veteran versus notrebek
of do satoroff the the 2021 World rapid
Champion he was the youngest in history
when he did it I'm on this is going to
be a fun one
it really is uh I I'm always excited
about battles of generations nordeback
is such a young player and so talented
Danny but you know as we dive into the
bracket you can see so many names there
but there might be one name that people
actually aren't seeing there
that's right well the the the name well
let's actually start at the top we're
going to start with carwana oh never
mind there we go we have a bit of a bit
of a switch around there we're gonna
we're gonna highlight right away that
yonda Palm machine has replaced dingley
Wren the world champion dingley Wren has
some personal stuff going on so we
replaced him with the world championship
Challenger and also a speed chess
champion Championship veteran in yonda
Palm Desi I don't know if you're our
Junior a guy see I'm on if that feels
like out of the frying pan to the fire I
think either way it's going to be a a
tough one there
yeah I don't I don't think he used them
too too differently everyone in this
competition is so dang strong but it's
nice to see you know the world champion
in the world championship challenge are
working together covering each other's
shifts that's nice
now we've got caruana abdusa turov the
8-9 seed as we said and as you saw from
that bracket the winner will move on to
face Hikaru Nakamura all roads or all
SCC dreams uh either fall short when you
run into a car Nakamura or or I guess
magic happens if your Magnus Carlson the
only man to do it a couple times so
that'll be interesting but neither
Fabiano or Notre back wants to think
about that right now they've got
business to attend to and I'm on let's
let's uh set the table for the fans who
maybe somehow are are just finding this
this amazing format for the first time
the speeches Championship is 16 players
you get a point for a win you get half a
point for a draw a zero for a loss just
like traditional chess but this knockout
uh moves to tie breaks if we are all
knotted up after the fastest portion we
get Armageddon chess and speaking of the
portions I'm on the the different
formats the different time controls the
clock running down so many things about
the SEC format make it great but once
you tell me what your favorite aspect is
well Danny now that the paycheck has
cleared I can definitely say that the
SEC is the Marquee online chess event
and no there was no paycheck I really
mean that and it's because of the exact
format you just mentioned Danny you
ultimately find out who the better chess
player is not overall maybe but on that
day in that match you have the increment
to make sure no one's out there just
dirty flagging you have the five minute
all the way down to the bullet portion
to make sure you test these players
across all aspects of their game so I
really feel like at the end of it you
know there is a deserving winner
agreed and you know you mentioned all
all the things it's nice when someone
else says it so I'm not the one I'm not
the one saying it but it is the best
format it it is the event that has
everyone stop what they're doing every
year
um and uh the the best player always
wins I think because of the way it's
staggered and how much time we get so
all right speaking of who the best
player is uh we're gonna find out at the
end of the day but right now we want to
bring up once again our Deloitte game
analytics the game within the game is
what Deloitte is all about they are a
perfect partner for chess.com their
mission is to dive in tell these stories
show all these amazing insights they're
an industry leader in their world we are
an industry leader in our world together
we bring you the Deloitte game analytics
and I'm on what stands out to you on
this page
I mean I I wish I could talk about uh
you know how evenly matched they are and
what we know about these players and
having played one another but that
actually hasn't happened on chess.com
Danny and it's crazy to think that these
guys are such regular players and
participants and so many chess.com
events and they've just never matched up
against one another so we're finally
gonna get to the bottom of this question
mark between these two players
it is amazing again like people are like
oh sometimes we highlight a matchup
where they haven't played in it and it's
not that random these guys play in title
Tuesdays these guys playing the
Champions chess tour uh they've both
played in scc's before and they didn't
get paired so that is actually a pretty
surprising fact uh and let's dive into
some more analytics here from Deloitte
uh there's there's a few different stats
we can highlight on this page I want to
jump well I want I want to get your
comments on their win percentage because
that actually seems kind of low and have
you comment on why that is maybe with
their style but also a huge disparity
disparity in total games played yeah a
number of things jump out here from the
Deloitte game analytics Danny definitely
the win rate and you know the fans
should remember that there's lots of
draws at this high level of Chess so you
know 30 win rate for both players is
significant but also look at the total
games Danny you see 232 for Fabi
definitely has the experience on his
side but you have the young you know up
and camera is he still up and coming or
is he already gone I don't even know
Danny but this is going to be an
exciting matchup between someone who's
used to the SEC and someone who's just
getting his feet wet
yeah the 232 games to 55 that is
speaking of being used to the format
right now Fabiano would like to improve
his best final position ever we saw
there those observant and fast readers
notice that he's never finished he's
never gotten into the semis actually and
so he'd love to get into the semifinals
and be one of the final four standing
this year uh Notre Beck of course is a
household name we expect for years to
come uh but um anyway gonna be gonna be
awesome we've got more things to break
down as we do before every matchup we
move from the analytics and the data to
smarter chess's predictions he uses data
to drive his uh his takes your thoughts
on a 55 45
favoring of Fabiano
I mean how else can you call a match
where you don't really know about these
players playing one another that's the
thing we haven't seen them play on
chess.com so I mean it pretty much has
to be a 50 50 that'd be definitely more
established but in order back I I feel
at this point is you know perhaps uh not
getting enough credit he'll look at that
five percent and say okay if it's a 50
50. how come it's skewed in his favor
it's funny because part of the part of
the toss-up you can just see by the five
five predicted score a modern bullet is
like smarter just like I don't know
what's gonna happen in Bullhead right
and you know I made it you made it you
made a call out when you and I were uh
in pre-show that sometimes we have a
closely predicted match and ends up
being a blowout sometimes it's a blowout
and it's close uh who knows but the fans
have something interesting to say about
that I think regardless of the smarter
chess predictions I was actually more
surprised to see this not taking
anything away from my boy Fabi but a 70
favorite against Notre back who a lot of
people appreciate as a young
up-and-comer very good at these fast
time controls
totally I think you know the fans are
just relating to who they've seen in the
SEC more uh who they're familiar with
more and you know being unfamiliar with
a player like norterbeck uh he's a guy
Daniel that'll let you know pretty
quickly what you're missing out on
yeah and and 70 for fans I think you you
hit the nail on the head and again
that's not taking anything away from
Fabiano it's because his name and
reputation right precedes him uh but I
think a lot of fans
voting for Fabiano he is the much more
recognizable name and I'm not saying
he's not the favorite but I would
probably lean a little closer to to the
experience getting the edge a lot
smarter chesses than I would a 70 favor
but I've been wrong and the fans have
been right before
that's right and uh you know going into
this match it's the eighth seed against
the ninth seed Danny so we talk about 50
50s but you know quite simply in any
event across the globe when you have
people that are seated pretty much 89
right in the middle of the tournament no
wonder it's going to be uh what should
be the most exciting but definitely the
closest match on paper
agreed and speaking of closest match on
paper we now have a close match on
camera Fabiano was just there a second
ago everybody I promise I don't know
what happened if he forgot he needed to
go to the bathroom or uh you know get
his hair did but he was just there I'm
on and he disappeared good hair he's got
some good hair
there he is there he is there he is he's
back
oh man and just like that a ghost He
vanishes he reappears looks like he will
get the white pieces first against Notre
Beck
um that's a stone cold killer there on
the right we've seen that very serious
face recently in a lot of the Champions
chess tour uh matchups and uh he's
comfortable in that spot with the white
wall behind him I was actually gonna say
these two players I'm kind of wondering
now thinking about a lot of the other
players obviously you've got your carbon
Nakamura super animated on his camera
um but are these like the most stoic
players like when I think Fabiano and I
think norterbeck I almost think zero
expression so I'm curious to watch the
cameras throughout this match
I agree they're very uh they are very
focused I guess you would say Fabiano
has has teased me and Robert often about
the fact that he feels like we read too
much into body language
um although he says that moves here we
do have some moves we're about to get to
the games he says that but we've also
seen him uh get very exasperated when he
knows he's Blown Blown a great position
um and so I stand by my abilities and
needs to read the mini catalog of Hikaru
Nakamura faces uh but either way you're
right these are two very focused and
stoic players yep
um I mean I'm already intrigued by this
opening Danny because really interesting
to see two players fienketto against one
another but the Bishops not be on the
same uh diagonal like the Bishop from C1
has just knocked out the A3
it is odd this is this is odd and uh I
don't know the opening that they got
here with
um I'm gonna quickly back up and just
run through it it was in English looks
like a symmetrical English up until this
moment with B3 and then as you pointed
out I'm on the bishop went to A3 rather
than the traditional diagonal and uh
and here we sit
after Queen to D2
but with the tension in the center whose
Bishop will end up being the uh getting
the last laugh I guess is the question
which diagonal opens up to favor the
other player well I I think the presence
of the bishop on A3 sort of directly
dissuades C takes D4 so usually white
would play D4 and then black would
capture it and maybe immediately respond
with D5 but with the bishop on A3 that
doesn't make a lot of sense so
immediately you're like actually maybe
sneaking this deep on from D4 to D5 for
white simply because of that Bishop on
A3
that's super interesting yeah I'm on
pointing out the tension now even more
so perhaps now favors white because with
the queen moving the D6 Pawn is also
hanging of course The Rook comes to d8
to try to help that but
yeah an advantage for white in my mind
and I'm not just saying that I promise
because of the eval bar biased itis over
here you pointed out the move d4 is
normally met by some sort of transition
here comes the space Advantage for white
that you called and Fabiano is dialed in
yeah I agree B5 this is to me a huge
Advantage for Fabi already now what
you'll see is that Bishop from A3 it's
sort of done its job Danny there's a
Pawn on D5 it's going to slide back to
B2 and all of a sudden it's like oh we
got this regular position but White's
got this Pawn on D5 it's not supposed to
be there
and this plot on D5 is a is a thorn not
just for the immediate space but it
blocks this bishop here and white now
has a bit of a benoni style structure if
you want to call it that where E4 F4
white can slowly expand and black is
really suffering for space over here
green yeah Queen on C8 Bishop B7 like uh
this is where White's gonna think about
moves like H3 but I don't even think H3
is needed invite the Knight to G4 and
then kick it out with H3 uh White has
just taken over the initiative and tempo
of this game Danny
yeah I was gonna say that I I was
suggesting it as a bit of a slow plan
that you might eventually play a benoni
structure for wife everybody says no no
let's go and as you pointed out he
doesn't even waste time for H3 this just
feels phenomenal for white you could
play
I have to say Danny this is almost like
I have no shame in admitting kind of a
weakness of mine when when white has
that edge and you know it here both
players are keenly aware last position
is a little bit behind but white has to
act quickly you have to be decisive here
if you don't push your advantage with
moves like F4 bringing the bishop back
E4 E5 if you don't do those things guess
what black is going to catch up
yeah I love it um well he plays Bishop
B2 by the way a bit of a discovered
thread at some point if this Knight
moves not only will D6 become tender
whether you go to E4 or B5 but if these
Bishops are traded the dark squares
become open for business and with all
these pieces trapped on the queen side
of mine you get worried that this could
become a blowout quickly white could
just burst through
absolutely
um a move like Knight H4 uh you know I
don't think that Knight is too happy
there it's a temporary threat but when
that Bishop gets saved Bishop H1 or even
Bishop H3 the move like Queen E1 uh on
the following turn it's just damn near
trapping the night
I love that I love that Fabiano just
hasn't held back here he plays F4 plays
G4
okay nice first play but I like I liked
your first suggestion but then I was
like maybe the second one coming to the
diagonal maybe you're right maybe that's
even more dangerous uh Bishop H3 like
obviously black gets some moves but let
me just describe my uh perfect world
here Bishop H3 G5 and Knight E4 all of a
sudden then the F6 square is just the
whites for the taking
wow he doesn't keep the bishop he
decides to let it be traded the computer
doesn't like it I don't know that you or
I thought that was the best move either
in that case we really agree there but
in the end White's Advantage is still
very strong and I guess he's pointing
out that maybe I lost that Bishop but
here comes everyone to the king's crew
true one of the most important pawns
though is the Pawn on F4 white would
want to stay away from playing the move
F5 just to it would hand over the E5
Square uh to Black so that pawn is
probably the most important and Knight C
to E4 and maybe pull into G5 that's how
I would look to continue with white here
so maybe Knight CD E4 right now
I love Knight CD for
offered the trade of the dark Square
Bishops note that you're not really
worried about anything on the C file
because your rook and pop to C1 and hit
the queen
yep there's also a move which is really
thematic here Danny is actually the move
B4 I don't know if it's the right idea
now because White's kind of gone all in
on the king side but it's a really
strong move it gives a pass Pawn to
black but you take the C5 Square the
bishop on B7 is blocked by the white
Pawn on D5 and the black Pawn on C4 so
it just takes the some some of the
prospects away from the black pieces
agreed B4 is super interesting I think
the risk of this move as you pointed out
is that whenever you're all in already
on one side of the board if you start
wasting time if B4 gets met by A5 and
and somehow you end up getting really
focused and black finds a way to open up
lines but but I like before
um
the more I think about it sorry go ahead
I was just going to point out the time
situation I feel like I'm always so into
the position Danny yeah but I I always
forget to look at the clock uh nordeback
hates his position and I don't blame him
he's spending a lot of time
yeah he's hated his position if we if we
go back and look at that uh the eval The
Evil game Arc below like the scoreboard
you can see that as soon as the uh move
D5 was played there from Fabiano those
those watching the advantage just got
better and better for white
um
all right now but but here's the point
you're all in on this attack you've got
every one of your pawns Advanced and
you've lost the light squared Bishop
around your king none of those things
seem to matter right now as long as
white is in charge and pushing but you
do have one of those positions that you
got to convert on otherwise if it opens
up white could get in trouble
totally uh this is actually a really
dangerous position for white it's not in
my opinion it's not as comfortable as of
an advantage for Fabi as he had five six
moves ago uh Black's pieces almost have
nowhere to go Ichiban B7 Rook on the a
file can't use a single entry square but
yeah the point is that they have nowhere
to go right now as soon as one of
White's pieces moves there will be a
weakness so it's just a really uh tense
position
and look how quickly notorbeck plays B5
very nice to point out the tactic if
Knight takes B5 Queen to B6 check picks
up the pony so you can't do that and
this cements the C Pawn opening up the
B6 Square for either the queen or maybe
the Knight to do business so you're
right among that there's a lot of
pressure on Fabi to convert now because
at some point Black's pieces are going
to get life over on the queen side and
that's why you see him playing moves
like G5 H4 because wise pieces are
almost situated no better than they
could be so the bishop on B2 Knight on
C3 they can hardly move so I think
that's why he's just going King H2 H5
like let me make some threats with my
pawns while my pieces are placed just
fine
yeah well now all right he's still got a
big advantage and with uh Notre back
under 20 seconds Fabiano would like to
convert this but this does have the
makings of one where you E5 F5 E5 F5 I
love that let's go
that's the song five F5
but it has the makings one of those
games I'm on if Favi doesn't cash in and
convert on on something like this
could get scary
to get loose
that's actually why I wanted to play E5
and then F5 because then I'm sure that
the Rooks while they've got an E Pawn in
front of them they actually can't ever
penetrate because of their own epon
yep well this is it it's either E5 now
or the advantage could start slipping
black would even exchange sack on e4 if
he could just to open up things against
the king so I think Fabian is taking his
time I'm on because he's gonna find it I
think he's calculating it yeah there's
there's moves like I don't know maybe F6
for for black and you know things can
spiral a little bit uh yeah here's that
move F6 I thought that was an issue to
allow because now if you allow F takes
G5 the E5 Square will become blacks
Knight F5 though what a move right there
what a move
black couldn't take it because the G
file was mate
yeah that was just uh Fabi like
definitely planned that when he played
rookie one
he was already anticipating F6 I almost
wanna we might back up and quickly look
at that as the next game gets started
and take advantage of the uh of the live
analysis board because that was a that
was a huge moment and what a great find
from Fabiano although
look at this compensation there's still
chances for notrebrecht this is not a
simple move
not at all Rook takes D3 if you like
almost has to happen
yeah you've got to get this okay now
that he wins the B5 Pawn feeling less
stressed about it if you're Fabiano
by the way Knight takes C6 is a threat
that's right yeah this is uh very tough
to play with low time for black that's
the main problem
both players under 10 seconds but an
extra exchange for white D6 is falling
okay a little bit scary here H6 will
will fall with check but where's the
beef after that
I guess he just runs the e-pawn here and
amazingly there's no like nasty checks I
was gonna say but Queen takes D5
yeah that's
this is getting crazy and there's no
time for oh my God the eval bar is going
crazy here black is
has black gotten himself a draw
King H2 Queen E5
oh my gosh unbelievable save how did
that
unbelievable Danny
honestly so let's
I would I would love to quickly pull up
that game really quick as the next one
gets started I want to back up we'll
pull up the live analysis board so that
fans can keep their eye on this opening
but in this position I'm on first of all
where did it get away from Bobby he was
winning
it was right here when he played Rook F2
or E6 I think the move E6 like the thing
is Black's Queen D4 check is easy to
underestimate because the only available
squares are G2 and H1 and then you
dropped a d Pawn with another check and
the black Bishop might get involved like
it's very scary at that point so uh
totally underestimated
and now he had to give back material we
were back in the game okay but earlier
it was this move Knight out of five they
caught our attention just to show
everybody you couldn't take because of
this move the discovered check followed
by winning The Rook which is why Knight
F5 earned the brilliant symbol so but in
the end all right on to the next game
yep somehow noderbeck saved the draw
there yeah it's like I think that game
was all Fabby but there's something that
top players tend to do in order back
pretty much example five right there
they're they're able to stay in the game
they never completely die right they're
like the villain in the in the movies
they seem to never die and look at that
he turned a almost a sure loss into a
half a point and now he's got the white
pieces
it's funny we talk about that with the
generation of players who who grew up
online and really a lot of them like
Nihao Sauron we refer to as even mini
hikaru-esque because Hikaru I think
Hikaru Nakamura has done that better
than anybody for the last 10 plus years
right literally snatching Victory or
sometimes stalemate from the jaws of
defeat but the young players among they
have the same attitude they have the
Never Say Die mentality because they've
already saved so many bad positions in
an online time scramble why would they
give up now right when you add a bunch
of Chess knowledge on top of that
they're able to do it against guys like
Fabiano caruana yep you said it they're
they are fearless and always willing to
fight I can't even think the amount of
times you see those guys like nordeback
Nihao furuja like they'll be in a
position that seems to be equal and
they're playing it like they're up a
queen or something like they're playing
to win every time
yep
all right well we're back to a Queen's
Gambit sort of special this this system
for those who don't know is is one of
Fabiano's uh well I guess he's one of
the more well-prepared players uh on the
planet ever so it's hard to say that but
I think this this particular system
against the Queen's Gambit declined is
one that he does well a Catalan uh kind
of move order but um
anyway right now Notre break is on the
clock thinking about what to do yeah
these positions are always uh tough to
understand for me personally because you
have this massive weakness on the king
side for white you so rarely in chess
want to fianchetto and then give up that
Bishop for night and that's like what
this opening is based on so it's
completely counterintuitive for me
um black has a light Square bishop and
white has massive light Square
weaknesses uh on his
yeah but the uh
the main issue
is that white has won a pawn to go with
it and so the the whole idea
sorry say that again
I lost you there for a second
okay
yeah the the main idea one was saying is
that the light squared Bishop is key but
in this variation what you get for it is
the pawn so white wins the pawn and
after taking on on D5 you're in a
position where even not just of one Pawn
you've got you've got other problems
here for black and so the positional
Edge that white has is very concrete to
compensate for the um there'll be Glide
squares so
um
all right we will uh continue here
looking at that we've got a poll from
chat still fans coming in strong 70 of
you voting there
for uh for Fabian oh I guess that's the
same poll we had earlier all right so
calling that out for chat
um the uh the fan vote is that many
people see Fabiana carvana as the
favorite here
um all right Queen to C6 now played
white wants to keep pressure on the on
the queen side long enough in order to
make sure that his light squares never
become a problem that's the idea uh but
after Queen to C6
black is faced with a pretty tough
question this is kind of irritating
because the Rook is under Fire you can't
move the Rook off the a file because the
bishop exactly and you don't want to
move it off the back ring because that
just feels wrong so instead you have to
play this passive move
but now here comes the developing bishop
and
opposite code Bishops in the end game
will be great for white here it's a no
lose kind of position where you're up a
pawn maybe you win maybe you don't so
white would be happy to win another pawn
and get the Queens off opposite code
Bishops in the middle game are what
black is ultimately hoping for in a lot
of these positions
so right now Fabiano takes his time
before deciding to allow the trade D4
for C7 Pawn
and uh
we'll see what happens here
um Rook takes D4
is played
and uh
Bishop so Bishop takes C7 instead of
Queen takes C7
I think a big part of that was actually
the the response move I'll back up and
show it real quick if Queen takes C7 I'm
pretty sure
black Mida wanted to keep the Queens on
the board and immediately set up a plan
on the diagonal
um perhaps so white is just not
interested in allowing that instead
trades and takes with the bishop
and we're headed for a position where
now even black
is uh is not able to get rid of the
bishop on C7 and no longer has the idea
of popping in on the diagonal here so a
little bit crazy here it's funny the
eval bar favors white in this position
rightfully so right whites up a pawn
it's a it's a healthy pawn two on one
but the light squares are a serious
problem and
um
if they ever get loose the black pieces
will go to town on the king side so I
think we've got them on Hamilton back
here good to have you with us sir his
name is I'm on Hamilton he is the chess
bro I'm on Hamilton
I think I think what happened there was
I was dropping some really crucial
knowledge on opposite Bishops yeah sort
of like a big brother moment like I was
giving too much away
no I was gonna say this relationship was
working you and I were bringing balance
to the force and the chaos the chaos
didn't want any part of it uh but you're
back and what's happened is white is
maintaining his one Pawn lead but black
is finally maybe getting the bishop and
Queen on the diagonal here your thoughts
yeah I I think that this is like what
black wants from from the opening white
is about to play F3 which is the reason
that this is not devastating
um but if you you see that epon move up
at all like to E3 I mean it's basically
good night Queen D5 will be made so I
think black is happy here Danny I know
you're down a clean Pond but as long as
the Queens are on the board you have
chances yeah and and you pointed out F3
is not a move that you really want to
play it's a movie you have to play in
order to to try to keep the lines at Bay
interesting Rook D5 there from Fabi now
is notorbeck just forced the Queens off
actually that's
I would call that an achievement yeah if
the Queen's come off the board you're
not as likely to get mated I will say
that
totally this is although the the eval
bar is hovering around equal uh big
achievement for white and now you know
with moves like F3 coming and Rook C2 I
think you're covering all of the tender
spots in your position and while it
might not be a winning Advantage Danny
it's an extra Pawn
yeah it's interesting and maybe maybe
Fabi miss queen C7 or just didn't think
he had enough there
um of course whenever you play these
systems as black your dream is to
Checkmate your opponent on the light
scores but you're also prepared for this
type of end game so Fabiano has probably
held this position more than a few times
in his life the bishop will try to come
to D5 at some point you basically say
look I'm down a pawn but I'm not gonna
let you win by blocking the light
squares
yeah so I don't know why Rook D2 is
allowed I think F3 was a lack of a
better word just a mistake
um yeah even if Rook D2 can be dealt
with you have to do some gymnastics that
you didn't sign up for Rook C2 I think
there was maybe bishop E4 on the
previous turn so black kind of had a few
answers for all of White's natural moves
so it was a difficult spot but he may
have chosen the wrong order here
yeah it's a really good point the more
I'm looking like why did he not just
stop Rook T2 now you have to guard B2
and the only way to do it is Rook B1
yeah and the thing is black is about to
put his Bishop on D5 which is
essentially gonna Force A3 and you know
once A3 happens Danny we're not really
speaking about an advantage for white
anymore it's just kind of dead even
what's funny is this move order actually
I highlighted the idea of Bishop D5 but
in this move order I think what Bobby
did was even better because Bishop A6
forces the defense and now black is just
winning back the pawn straight up with
Rook to V8 so
who's look at I mean I know it's
obstacled Bishops a month but what kind
of winning chances you give black here
given that this is a spot that white can
never really fix maybe there's just not
enough beyond that though
I think that's exactly right just not
enough beyond that and a lot of times
what might happen in the worst case is
that black wins the E2 Pawn but he won't
be able to win it and keep the Brooks on
the board
yeah
so we'll see well he's definitely gonna
push it
yeah he's he's gonna push it at some
point you always have to be careful not
to allow some sort of uh backtrack for
example I just have to show quickly
instead of H3 like if okay never mind HG
had to be played first but if e3's ever
played you give a check and the King has
made it except for E4 and then black can
get F5 and actually suddenly black is
winning because of the lights
yep and this is a very tricky spot
mainly because of the time Danny so I'm
just noticing he's down to a couple
seconds that's not a good place to be
but Rook G1 is insanely resourceful
of the two players you think of Notre
Beck as being the younger Speed Demon
but the truth is to this point two games
in Fabiano has been the one managing his
clock better and there's a weird mating
net here you played like Rook H2 if Rook
G3 there's Bishop B7 check okay okay The
Rook keeps an eye on the B7 Square
yep
and I wonder how many pawns you can give
away here
um as black like the move let's say Rook
B2 King F3 I was looking at Bishop C4
and putting the bishop on D5 don't care
about the a pawn don't care about the H
pawns give me the two connected pawns
like that's kind of tricky
look at him walk into the face of danger
too of the Discover check that's Fabiano
caruana playing for a win here
especially because his young opponent is
down to four seconds
H4 Bishop H7
yeah no now you have to go it's uh gut
check time do you play Rook takes H3 and
basically take the draw no he wants to
try to win Fabiano is continuing to push
this look at that oh my God one second
he literally made that move
that's insane yeah Rook B5 I think the
eval bar is not as important as just the
you know the Practical chances here the
clock exactly
and Fabiano picks off another Pawn gets
The Rook coordinated let's not okay that
a pawn is very dangerous but let's not
underestimate how much better Fabiano's
pawns are here everyone the connected
passers are way better but wait a second
has probably blundered is that pawn gone
too far
yeah the thing about the the setup that
white has is Bishop on C5 covers the
pawn so now you bring the Rook to to hit
the promotion Square
yeah that's just a huge huge mistake
huge mistake there and Fabiano resigns
frustrated because he kind of created
his own problems there right he pushed
for a win when he didn't have to and
eventually lost now as you know the
resident person who gives chat a heart
attack getting into time scrambles here
Danny I can certainly speak and say
sometimes you do it to yourself you get
low on time you lose those games to
Fabby and you're kicking yourself like
what am I doing with three seconds
against a guy as strong as Fabby but
sometimes you know you are just super
resourceful and Fabio overpressed is
thinking oh I'll just beat him on the
clock no I mean nordvac is insanely
resourceful and just as talented when
he's got three seconds
yeah
the chat is already blaming me and we're
only 20 minutes into the show I didn't
Jinx Bobby there okay Fabi did it to
himself I'm on Hamilton said it which is
he pushed for a win in a spot where
honestly we weren't blaming him right
half the time we're like look at this
he's pushing on the clock he's got two
connected passers he blundered and
allowed that a-pawn to get out of
control but you know if your father own
a car wanna right now you got to focus
on the positive which he seems to be on
Forum I know he's down a game and it's
weird that I'm saying that but I feel
like they're they're both playing well
and Bobby has to just forget about the
actual result of that game
totally
um and so far we've seen a consistent
pattern of educator of getting low on
time
and I think that's really going to be
the story here how do both players
handle that situation because you never
want to get suckered into playing in
your opponent's time pressure like
playing as fast as them you want to use
it against them and we saw Fabby sort of
you know take the wrong approach there
but you know he's a seasoned
professional uh Danny so I think he's
going to adjust
yeah he should he should adjust
um you'd expect him to but shout out to
the youngster was still 63 minutes and
40 seconds remaining on the total five
minute segment for those of you who
might be new to the speed Chess
Championship
we have an hour more of five minutes
before we move on to faster time
controls so plenty of Chess ahead a
long-winded way of saying that
absolutely this is a kind of weird
position like I'm impressed that the
eval bar doesn't hate Black's position
more
um because I'm looking at this double b
pawns uh B4 Pawn in particular needs the
knight's support from C6 which is why
the move D5 is so so logical
yay plays D5 although we'll say this not
to not to you know um continue to double
down on the point that fobby is down on
the scoreboard but he's gotten good
positions I think in like all three
openings a month right and he has yet to
get a win so he was he was he was
borderline winning in the first game if
you got here late uh should not have
lost that second game you saw that time
scramble so even though I like Bobby's
position he has the past D Pawn he still
hasn't converted
that's right and there's going to be a
ton of counter play here on the a file
rook d288 and you know that that Apon
it's not easy to defend Rook C2 Bishop
A4 so there's already ways that you can
sort of hoop yourself here is white
it's a funny stat right there this is
his third appearance in the SEC but the
first time he didn't face Wesley so in
the first round well there you go it's
good not to play Wesley I guess I don't
know
yeah that will that will definitely help
your uh you know final placement stats
just not playing Wesley in round one I
hear that helps a lot yeah and we're not
taking anything away from Fabiano but
Wesley so as I said when I commentated
his his match Victory last week has only
lost to two men in the SEC format and
they are Hikaru Nakamura and Magnus
Carlson so you can make an argument that
Wesley so is the third best speed chess
player on the planet as far as online
chess goes anyway so
um all right but here we go Queen B4
from Fabi I think it's a bit of a draw
for from the perspective that if the
Queens come off we get b-pawn for a pawn
although wait a second maybe I'm
misspeaking right white does white has
white has an advantage if that happens
so
yeah I think also there's
um you know the move B5 uh could be
played and you're sort of saying okay
maybe I'll take that a pawn later but
White's about to play Rook D2 Rook B2
and everything is covered
am I crazy for spotting this move here
I'm just like
I think that was interesting Bishop yeah
exactly was it it was a move you're not
crazy Danny
you're not crazy you're a lot of things
but not crazy I'm a lot of things thank
you sir all right Rook takes A2 the B
Pawn will fall
white is up Bishop C6 is there just like
six
is that just uh you know drone boring
old draw
so I guess if your car one are you
considering whether you have more here
but it's a risky move right if you don't
just simplify You could argue the bishop
is the better minor piece for example
okay you go for this but if if we get a
position where the bishop and pawn can
get going I'm nervous although the more
I look at it I probably would have
played on two 95 you have a past D Pawn
it's hard not to think white has a
little bit of something here
right I guess there's a setup maybe
White playing like Knight C4 to V6 where
you're blocking the pawn and Defending
Your Own Pawn there's like a few setups
here but the bottom line is if you just
dislodge the Knight F6 rookie two these
types of moves I I think there's no way
that this doesn't especially with the
amount of time that these players have
Danny it's not like we're dealing with
seconds here they have like almost half
the time on their clock I'm sure that
this will be a drop
this is the opposite of the first two
games we saw where both players were
still in completely complex craziness
when they when they had no time on the
clock so this one way simpler Knight to
C4 I think can be met by Rook to E4 so
that's a little bit you got to be a
little worried about self-pinning
so if Bobby's thinking twice about that
but if you play F4 that's a move you
can't take back so instead he he goes
for the more passive and subtle maneuver
that's right
yeah the Knight can go to F4 but it's
not really stable in that square there's
always G5
um
I guess the only thing to watch out for
for black is if things start to
establish on the dark squares so if
white gets D6 Knight C5 Rook B6 some
kind of setup like that but he's he's
certainly going to be uh healing in the
aware of that
and to do some Grand Master translation
of why he just said the dark squares for
those who maybe didn't get the memo
whenever you're playing against someone
who only has one color Bishop you have
to always be thinking strategically
about the color complex they can't
attack and so if you can put some sort
of whether it's an oppressive grip or
whether it's a blockade on the opposite
colors of the bishop
you you can Dominate and at times it can
feel like you're up a piece because that
Bishop is just not partaking so anyway
just wanted to point that out because
that was a really nice idea Mon and note
that Notre Beck is not allowing it but
I'm still liking the general direction
of this game for Favi I like Knight
before I like D6 I like Knight C6 right
this he's pushing here
yeah he definitely is uh he's keeping it
alive the the interesting thing about
pawns like this on D5 is
um
although they are a pass on there's
something innate about them which is
that they're closer to the enemy King so
wax King will become a participant soon
in the game especially the more pieces
that get traded and the pawn will become
let's say weaker and weaker or easier
for black to attack whites can can't
just jump up to C6 and participate as
well so it's easier for Black's King to
get involved yeah
right on cue as you were making that
point a Rooks a pair of Rooks are traded
and the King enters in and here comes
Fabi trying to keep up keep up pace
yeah now I think uh you know basically
you'd like to replace your Rook with
your king in terms of defensive Duty
um covering the Deep on and use the Rook
more actively Rook C2
et cetera
yeah I wondered if Rook D4 was the
Better Block hit I'd love that Knight on
B4 just for all the things it did there
already but Fabiano does relocate the
Knight
as you said Notre Beck is getting his
King in by the way remember how we said
there was no time pressure we might
still be playing this game in two
minutes and that that changes
that's a good point actually and there's
been time pressure pretty much every
game so why should this one be any
different
yeah all right well all right that's it
okay never mind right as we said a
commentator's curse we jinxed them they
might as well I think he did it for a
reason Danny I I think that only white
risks losing that position at some point
because the black black has the outside
pawn and the d-pawn could be lost so not
that that was close to happening but
Bobby was like okay I'm not gonna win
this game what am I doing here I think
he evaluated it correctly and I'm a
super great defense from Nordica but
obviously Fabiano's down right now but
mature decisions like that I'm on show
experience and if he does come back in a
match you will all of us will have
forgotten that game I'm predicting now
we won't remember that game but it's a
huge game it's like the moment of know
when to hold them no one to fold them
right when the pot odds are stacked
against you like what are you doing in
the hand get out and and I loved your
point about that that outside pass Pawn
that black had because I think a lot of
players I'm on will play that out and
then later they blame time pressure
because they lost or they blame a
blunder but they actually just didn't
strategically play the right you know
hand right they were pushing a position
they didn't have any business winning
and think that's instructive for the
viewers
totally and it comes with experience and
not to say that nordbeck lacks uh
experience in this case but simply the
more games you play like online those
guys will probably play that position
out guys like Hikaru Nakamura will play
that position 100 times so when he gets
into a real game he's like uh I've
played this 100 times and I've pushed it
successfully you know most of the time
I'm gonna play here or the opposite and
I'm gonna you know
make this a draw because we don't need
to get too crazy
right
all right well here we go we are in game
four one game is the lead for Notre
bakura thanks for being here chat
boys and girls ladies and gentlemen
Wherever You Are
we would um I mean we would just be
crazy people Danny if we were just
talking to one another the chat really
makes this experience the chat really
makes this experience thanks for
bringing your positive comments we try
to feature them throughout the day
um and uh and yeah all right well we're
in another cattle land well no actually
no we're in more of a traditional
what exactly are no it is a Catalan okay
it that's right it's a Catalan but more
of a traditional looking Catalan than
the the one we saw last game
I think the the main difference was
previously white gave up the bishop for
the night on C6 and here black traded
the Knight on C6 for the Knight on E5 so
just a deviation from there from the
first time that they played this and
that's why I always say I'm excited for
the five minute portion of these SEC
matches because it's a experimentation
phase where players test out their
different openings and you get to see
which ones work which ones don't and
these players can adapt pretty quickly
on the Fly
yep
yep I think I Now understand that who
will win today thing I think that's the
real-time odds that we're showing
because if Fabiano came in slightly
favored that means right now with
notorbeck leading by one the odds would
suggest that they're about a 50 50 split
um and I'm just
oh it's the chat poll okay it's a
real-time chat poll okay well I hadn't
gotten that confirmed by anyone until
just now the producer confirmed so there
you go
um a little bit of context goes a long
way 50 50 is impressive like it's
straight down the middle in the chat
okay I like it yeah okay well thank you
Chad for playing along and we see it
being updated in real time as you're
voting
twitch and YouTube combined look at our
stats here twitch and YouTube combined
to bring us that real-time chat
um I love it well right now we've got
notorbeck taking a real-time think here
he's been on the clock for more than a
minute but this is a critical position
these cattle lands I when you said you
were excited for the 5-1 portion I'm on
there's the Practical stuff you talked
about right the gamesmanship of what
openings are they trying out they're
jockeying poking for weaknesses but
there's also theory that gets played in
these five minute portions sometimes
it's pretty high quality in deep Theory
where you're like where you're looking
at improvements they have there's a lot
of money on the line in these SEC so
look at this Notre pick finds according
to the computer the best approach by
trading and playing Queen E4 it hits the
Rook you can't play C6 because I'll just
take that pawn oh he does play C6 I I
think white will take the one
it's an interesting move because it
almost looks like Queen takes C6 Queen
C8 or something
um
trying to think though because you can
see that you can take that Queen and
then play Knight takes B5
um yeah and the Knight on D7 all right
analysis board to the bat cave we
shouced Let's Do It
um let's go we're looking at ideas like
Queen to C8 takes takes Knight takes B5
and if this happens
I mean it might just be a whole you know
fancy way of saying it's equal but yeah
I mean yeah these guys have to calculate
all that
so that's one line the other option is
apparently Queen to B6 is a move
but it's similar in that if you take you
still have to deal with the Knight so
what is happening here I don't get it oh
there's Knight D5 at the end very nice
yeah yeah that looks good
okay
so
I wonder whether either of these players
are still in some form of prep again
whenever we think of Fabiano caruana we
always
I think uh he would say we give him too
much credit
um but he tends to be very very deeply
versed
and here he does finally play Queen C8
it seems like the most natural move to
me
um
yeah I definitely don't think there's
any serious Advantage the the pun on E5
needs you know defensive attention from
White it also blocks the bishop
um but if you can liquidate the queen
side pawns white will have some small
Advantage waiting for him later
um the problem is that seep on Danny is
actually really strong so even in all
the lines we've been looking at that
pawn lives on and the bee Pawn Falls
right
well Knight takes B5 is played but I I
agree okay wow we're getting a big old
Desperado tactics right Galore
Knight takes E5 referred to as brilliant
partly because the idea would be that if
you take you lose the knight in the
obvious fashion here black picks up a
pawn first uh as a quick way to get some
material but after white takes and takes
I think this is actually just fine for
white because the bishop is maybe more
ideally placed for okay well wow they're
just they don't want to take pieces here
man
yeah it's funny they don't want to take
pieces uh and then they're actually
creating the biggest imbalance possible
so both guys are actually really willing
to fight here but I give some extra
credit to an order back because he had
like Bishop takes E5 Bishop C3 like who
the heck cares he's up in the match move
on but like I said Danny these younger
players the younger generation they're
just here to fight they're here to play
every position out until there's just
Kings on the board and that fighting
spirit is so awesome to watch
agreed agreed every game will go down to
the wire and as we keep saying it's
because they've grown up online if you
will they've won equal Rook endings
you're not supposed to win right they've
flagged their opponent ruthlessly enough
times that they don't even think about
it anymore right
um and uh so by the way Rook to D1
pokes at a back ring problem
for those keeping track
um
and you can't really move the F Pawn I
mean I suppose you can do a number of
things because the B Pawn is hanging but
yeah generally I think you needed to
play H6 or H5 and uh you know White's
probably gonna play things like F3 E4
King coming to the the middle of the
board and if C3 happens I think White's
ready to play B3
wow just
just keep keep the pressure here white
is ultimately relying on on one Dynamic
which is that the bishop will probably
be a better piece than the Knight if we
get some past pawns flying you know if
white somehow is is coordinating to win
something the bishop is a better piece
and I like a month's plan of F3 ring the
king behind the structure the reason I'm
liking Notre Exposition is I feel like I
see those moves for him to improve how
exactly is black improving this position
I mean it takes a very strong player to
restrict the Knight but he'll probably
what white will do probably leave that
epon on E2 for now because you just
don't want to allow 95 to D3
um and like when the Knight thinks about
maybe going to D5 that's when on e4
makes more sense but you can always
leave it in reserve and play it later
once the Knight arrives there so I think
white just has the options
and this this 97 was a mistake and I
wonder if it has something to do here
with these pieces because
yeah you've got you've got ideas where
the The Rook can give check and then you
can bring the bishop out and you sort of
take advantage of the awkwardness oh he
plays Bishop before first but the same
idea he wants to play check and even if
you're not winning the exchange he wants
to somehow get the Rooks on the seventh
Rank and take advantage of of the pieces
here
if this seems to allow some kind of F6
E5 like if he plays Vision C3 then
Knight D5
if we bring up the analysis board real
quick we'll show exactly what it was
because we see a missed opportunity here
revealed and that's exactly it actually
was the idea we were talking about this
Rook can move to d8 and when this Rook
moves you come back to D7 and you're
actually creating a bunch of problems
here or or actually you bring the other
rook in but in either case this was the
opportunity White had
yeah that's that's really really nice
um and now that it hasn't been played
you see that I think Fabius is a little
bit happier with the position
um Bishop on C3 versus C1 surprisingly
actually means a lot for the position
yeah and fobby's gotten the night in and
now he comes to B5 which if he can force
The Rook ending he'd probably be happy
at this point
um
Notre brick doesn't want it
how many time scrambles with a knight in
Bishop and balance are we gonna see in
this match can we get an over under on
on that from chat
um this is I think the third one
yeah it's uh it's become routine for
these guys so they're just used to it at
this point
um I mentioned this in the last position
but White's King will be slightly more
useful than Black's King when it comes
to maybe this Advanced C Pawn or the end
game in general so see how they played
out
wow C3 what a spicy move note that if
takes takes in Rook C2 there was Knight
D1 discovered check so that was the key
white plays Rook C2 first
but now I think we can get a trade if
you take B2 Rook takes and then you move
the Knight to safety maybe that's what
black should do
no uh yeah you have to go Knight D6
there
um wow nice C7 best move according to
the computer you hit the Rook so you're
once again inviting The Rook ending
we're getting a big old trade
because I mean this is just evening out
completely
Knight C5
yeah Rook B7 I guess is just simple
okay but two seconds for Notre back he
likes living on the clock he's not
afraid to Dive Into the Danger here man
I do think that most players just have
this opinion that you know the Knight is
kind of better than the bishop when you
get over on time and it's definitely
correct so this will be about whether
norterbeck can handle the bishop Knight
Dynamic with low time yeah which is
seriously tough to do and look here
comes a fork it's the first night threat
and it wins A4 notarbeck makes his first
night blunder there you go
and you were you called him man that was
uh that was a nice one and now you're
threatening rookie Rook to B2 hitting
the E2 Pawn yep
nice gonna come to E6 into D4 and then
the Rook will maybe renew this threat
yeah so Bishop E3 is the Annoying move
it needs Knight V6 and It's just tough
to like get the pieces mobile here um if
you're black yeah but we shouldn't
underestimate how important this is for
Fabiano because he's down a game in the
match even if objectively white should
hold from a practical perspective as you
said the Knight is better than the
bishop the tactics and time pressure
should favor Black don't play Knight C4
huh
that that would have been a piece
six I think you can try Knight C4
now you can yeah Notre Beck is holding
on though credit to the youngster and
don't think that white has no winning
chances either because this is in a
similar vein to what Fabio overpressed
last time you know if you try too hard I
do think there's still room for things
to to go wrong oh you just blow to the
pond and Fabiano shakes his head
um and just like you said
are there chances to go wrong right now
he's gonna put the Knight on F7 and hold
so he's got that going for him
what happens here okay yeah
when the game happens man I tell you I'm
just a tour of he has a style that's
very difficult for me to pinpoint so I'm
just gonna use one word It's just tough
he's just he's just gritty he never
quits on the position and his ability to
save results is so impressive to me
I I could have said it better myself so
I won't even try he he has persevered
under real pressure multiple times
already in today's match and we're just
getting started this is our first kind
of halftime break in the five minute
portion he takes a one game lead over
Fabiano caruana
um again if you're just tuning in you
might want to stick around this has the
makings of what could be a thriller
Carbono is slightly favored coming in
has the lead quick thoughts on what
fabi's thinking that before we head to
the break
well right now I think you kind of hit
the nail in the head earlier and you
said that he's actually in form and I
kind of agree so I think he's just going
to be thinking about the uh time
pressure that he's been able to put in
order back in and how he can use that to
his advantage
that's a great point he has played well
this match is a close one I think it's
going to stay that way don't go anywhere
it's the 2023 speed Chess Championship
it's presented by coinbase it has a lot
more action ahead when we get back
thank you
welcome everyone we are here with Judith
Polgar the legendary chess player one of
the greatest chess players of all time
[Music]
and I went to my next move I said no I'm
not moving my queen I'm not moving my
Bishop but actually I'm going to give
Checkmate or winning great material and
I went 93.
it works only that way if you are
attacker you sacrifice something go all
the way until the end don't chicken out
in the meantime at some point because
many times there is a point there is no
way back it's only forward
[Music]
[Applause]
how is it to play with casparo when you
saw him personally
he really had this incredible energy
shoot it thank you so much for being
with us and I hope you hope you're ready
to to dive into the past with us oh
absolutely I'm very happy to share with
you some of my most memorable games
[Music]
I'm Andrea and I'm Alex and we've been
playing competitive chess since we were
six years old
kind of by focusing on classical chess
but later we fell in love with playing
Blitz and bullet online
chess has been around for more than 1
000 years but that doesn't mean that we
can't modernize it Financial systems
have been around for even longer sounds
like it's time for an update and
coinbase is doing just that
re-envisioning an entirely new Financial
system that is decentralized and fully
transparent
also huge thank you to coinbase for
sponsoring competitive chess and making
events like the SCC happen go to
coinbase.com update the system to learn
more
foreign
[Music]
Championship it's presented by coinbase
he's I'm on Hamilton Danny wrench here
we got a close one developing here Iman
but uh before we talk about the
scoreboard and get into what both
players might be thinking about let's
remind everybody of Fabiano caruana and
his career I'm gonna let you kind of
Take The Wheel a man that hardly needs
an introduction he's overcome more than
a one-game deficit before your thoughts
yeah I mean we're talking about a you
know a multiple time US champion too to
be precise Danny I mean that already
says a lot when you think about the
competition that he's got there
um also how about the theater World
Championship runner-up I mean this is
the guys you see him there on your
screen who uh honestly he doesn't really
look the part he's just hanging out you
know he's got the pro out and uh who
would know that behind those uh those
lenses is uh such a chest Talent game
super chess talent and again you know we
we talk about the fact that uh he had a
reputation for a while that we thought
was overblown as far as not being as
strong in in the faster time controls
and I think he's he's been a consistent
participant in the SEC because he gets
out of the first round all the time the
guy is putting pressure on the top seeds
even if he hasn't made it to the semis
and you know he knows his way through
the speeches championship format I don't
think he's rattled because he's down by
a game right now
I don't think he is
um I mean I don't think uh to be quite
Frank uh that any player in this
competition would be rattled being down
a game everyone knows just how uh
momentum based the speech has
Championship can be and speaking of
momentum that's what the break can kind
of be good or bad for certain players
for because it can break someone's
momentum uh as you know maybe uh that
that break is going to be the perfect
refresh for someone like Fabi to just
say okay take a step back we're down a
game Let's collect ourselves and try to
use the time pressure that he's put
abusator of in almost every game and
look at that speaking of collecting
ourselves and maybe rethinking the math
strategy he goes back to the first
opening he tried if you're just tuning
in game one today saw Fabiano Carmina
want to play this variation of the
symmetrical English and get a pretty
good position as white ultimately he
failed to win that game but it's the
closest he's come to a dub yet so look
at him I'm on going right back to it but
but look at but look at Notre back he
says guess who looked at this opening at
the break bro I know what I'm doing now
yeah he made one key change which is not
like going to Disturbed uh Fabiano
greatly but the move of course was Queen
to A5 so yeah just one simple move it
hits the bishop on A3 forces it to go
back to B2 and the one thing that it
does is it just removes any of that d4d5
stuff that white was getting in the
previous game however Abby's not upset
because Queen A5 now he's playing a
regular position where Black's Queen
might be misplaced that's why he moved
it back yeah interesting stuff high
level footwork going on between two
chess heavyweights here
and uh
and I like your point yeah those who've
been here the whole time will remember
that Fabiano kept his Bishop on A3 and
ultimately that diagonal was why he got
great pressure and got the advantage so
even though
um I'm with you Iman that his position
isn't bad now just because he doesn't
have the bishop on A3 I think from a
practical perspective I'm happy to see
Notre Beck using his break well he knows
that was a weakness he went back clearly
took a look at it and now he's up on the
clock and in a better position at least
that he had in game one
absolutely and just such Focus from both
players I always point this out because
I I do think it's truly unique when
you're playing over the board chess the
way that nordbeck is thinking right now
is actually really common but I hardly
ever see anyone do this online it's just
a really weird thing to take both your
hands off the mouse it's like it's kind
of like having no hands on the steering
wheel while you're driving yeah he's
just like whoa wait a minute
well it shows you the the level of focus
they're bringing right oh they do it in
over the board tournaments because those
are historically where the highest
Stakes chess were played that was before
before the internet before chess.com and
and all the online entities were hosting
big money events and what we've got here
is is is frankly two players who are
taking this very seriously right he puts
his hands on his head because he's
focused and he's dialed he is dialed in
and he's obviously done some work on
this line I like the the fact that
um right now what we're probably gonna
see is I would assume Bishop takes B2
I don't think there's Knight takes C5 so
Bishop B2 Knight B2 and then what he'd
love to do is something like V6 and
Bishop B7 but
um interesting that he goes for Queen D6
first
if we G6 to guard the pawn the funny
thing about that is
yeah if you play Queen C2 now and hit
the pawn
I guess B6 can still be played but maybe
white doesn't want that does white want
to go for D4 and perhaps that's why he
put the queen on the diagonal maybe to
kind of stop that totally I think I
think that's a fantastic Point Danny and
well noted that if B6 D4 would have been
a strong reply
um and now that's not an option so
Abby's kind of pausing because wait a
minute Danny you're not supposed to fian
Kettle your Knights right on B2 I know
D3 I mean this is a weird night right
now
and he tries to fix it but now the
Knight is in front of a pawn and here
comes a bishop to a diagonal that might
make it feel even more Awkward than it
already does
um
so Bobby brings the Knight to F4 it's
not every day you see a a game where
white has delayed moving the center
pawns this long right white is really
refusing to play D3 or D4 and at some
point black might get D4 and try to grab
a space advantage to make the pain
that's right
um the Knight on E7 is actually doing
like a a very important job defending
the Knight on C6 it might not look like
it but there's a lot of moves like B4
and D4 that just don't hit as hard
because the Knight on C6 is well
protected because technically you know
Black's not really finished development
yet he hasn't decided where to put that
C8 bishop and it could go either
direction Bishop A6 Bishop F5 Bishop G4
yeah you know it's a really good point a
very common tactic in this sort of it's
almost like a maroxy bind kind of style
position if the Knight is loose is to
make a shot like D4 B4 but that's not
possible here it's a really good point
and and so now black is getting extra
aggressive with the bishop coming out to
A6 it's funny the computer doesn't like
it but I think this is exactly what a
human being would do here to put the
bishop on the slightly more active
position especially because if you go to
B7 and that diagonal ends up getting
blocked
um so anyway this looks like a very
equal game full of of time pressure
scrambling ahead here
yep and I I really like your move d4
from black that that seems like the
right idea I think at the moment maybe
one of the reasons why it's not as good
is the Knight on E7 uh will be loose
from The Rook on E1 but if that wasn't
the case I I really love the move d4 for
black and there's one thing that
norderbeck probably wishes he could
change about his position and he's
probably his Pawn on A7 being on A5 it's
just a feel-good uh you know Pawn
structure to have the pawn in front of
your Bishop guarding the B4 Square so
you're not blocking anything yeah
that's a really good point um and if he
had more time you probably would have
tried to set up that thing but he didn't
although now that you've said D4 I want
to analyze that because I've been I've
been staring at D4 and I don't actually
see any tactics for white on it so let's
try it yeah yeah computer thinks it's
fine for black too because if you take I
think you can even just I mean you could
probably take with Pawn or Knight but I
think this is fine and there's no real
tactics so
I love the transition here a computer
might still say that white is a little
better here everyone but this is getting
better and better for black just look at
the Optics of where these pieces are
freaking placed here this is like it's a
problem so I love D4 he doesn't go for
it but maybe maybe he should have
I think there's something about D4 where
black would love to play EK C4 Knight
takes D4 and maintain uh pressure on the
d-pawn for white and maintain a piece on
D4 but after Knight takes his first he's
forced to play CD4 because of that
Knight on E7 uh so that's that's the
issue that he's facing he needs to play
like Knight F5 first but both players
kind of know that that's the dance right
now
okay that that's fair we didn't analyze
that but at the end of the line was a
pawn you're right then black doesn't
have those Optics that I was
highlighting that just looks so pretty
now Bobby probably Was preparing to meet
D4 with E4 with this Pawn on D3
yep
yep I I think you know you're okay with
that for both sides honestly I think
it's just a dynamic position
why would you translate I translate the
grand masters from time to time
translate the computer here why does why
does the engine like white in this
position just by a little bit
well I think that there's uh the move B4
is always on tap and B4 is actually a
really distracted move to Black's
position so black always needs to keep
it in mind Queen D2 is directly for the
move B4 so it definitely feels like
white has this move to keep black always
needing like a pawn or a knight covering
it and then you want to go D4 but
there's pressure from the G2 uh to B7
Bishop just pressure from The Rook on E1
to the E7 Knight Brook on C1 to the now
C7 Rook so there's just a lot of things
that black has to keep in mind and the
move d4 kind of strikes at all these
things at once so I think just too many
things to uh to keep covered for for
black and I mean he's certainly done a
great job keeping them covered so far
but it's that constant need to defend
things and watch over things
okay
thank you sir I'm gonna ask you to
translate the computer more often I feel
like I could fall asleep to that some
ASMR I'm on Hamilton translating
stockfish you ever thought about that
yeah that's uh
that's a really good idea you know maybe
ASMR amman's stockfish meditation rehab
dude I I would fall asleep to you
translating stockfish evaluations and in
the best way in the best way not in any
um all right well look Rook C3 C4 is
played
um black is keeping it closed
and in the end as he can oh he doesn't
pop then I didn't I thought he would go
Knight B3 and A5 instead he Retreats
it's funny here the computer doesn't
like white as much although I look at
the d-pawn as being such a big weakness
with the Knight and Bishop here but
maybe maybe the C4 Pawn being being
secured is actually a very good
long-term Advantage for black
yeah I think if black could play the B5
move that you were highlighting it would
be a serious uh position for black so
actually Fabi probably uh picked a great
moment to play B5 himself
okay it's really interesting to look at
that where you keep your opponent's
pawns from being connected with that uh
with that little incision there
yeah and I'm taking a look at the king
side here and I'm almost waiting for the
like you know when is the H6 G5 for
black gonna happen I think King G7 uh
basically things are kind of closing up
on the queen side they're they're I
don't know if there's much more to be
done so you're gonna see the play
transition to the middle of the board
and the King side is what I'm expecting
and I anticipate that maybe white should
have played a move like E4 while he had
the chance it's a scary move to play but
if the if this I'm just highlighting if
somehow black ends up getting pieces on
e4 then I'm really really worried about
what might happen next oh what is that a
piece nice hanging he just blunder
tonight it is and he missed it the knife
is hanging oh my God
and she is Fabby gonna realize it
because Fabby oh dude did you see that
look
Fabby hasn't noticed yet as far as I can
see but that's an insane blunder and
it's almost like both guys did not
expect them to blunder so they weren't
looking for it
dude and anyone who backs up clip it and
ship it for social media fans Notre Beck
saw that he got away with murder there
yeah
wow it's almost a good thing that Fabi
doesn't notice because if Fabi started
to realize that he had a free piece and
didn't take it he might be playing this
position on more tilt than he currently
is right I totally agree sometimes the
ignorance is bliss as they say right
that's right you can analyze later and
realize you missed a win but not during
97. he's blundering everything Fork Fork
Fork let's go five dude this is actually
turning into worse worse signs for
Fabiano because if he's missing these
obvious wins oh my gosh oh it's crazy
and he's still got a winning position
let's say a better position Danny how
crazy is that
it is crazy but if he doesn't win this
game
what a bad sign that is for finding out
of carwana fans because it's not missing
one win is one thing but when you have a
game where you miss multiple wins that
that may not spell okay it's Knight
takes E6 just winning on the back rank
okay he does see that game over
yeah wow that should be enough
um yeah okay he's amazing he does get
that win I still don't know if Abby saw
that but if you're an order back here
you have to be thinking in your head
like okay we kind of deserve to lose
let's bring up the analysis board real
quick I just want to show the end of
that game because it was it was resigned
but I think for a lot of people it may
not be so obvious right at the end
Knight takes E6 is actually a great move
a queen sacrifice if you want to show it
because if Rook takes C3 we have Rook A8
Shack puzzle rush time everybody blocks
and in the end you're trying to move as
fast as you can like I'm on Hamilton
because you're like I gotta get to 40.
and you all you have to do is take every
piece on the way to mate so just wanted
to show that before we head back over to
the live game in progress so
yeah and it's it's so weird isn't it the
truth Danny though like you you
obviously were watching the highest
level of Chess being played the highest
level players but they still have the
exact same moments as the rest of us
where you blunder something and your
opponent doesn't notice and it's almost
like you and the opponent have the same
exact blind spot at the same exact time
it's funny how in sync uh you can be
with your opponent sometimes it it
really is and I don't even know that it
has anything to do with telekinesis Kyle
right shout out to uh Tenacious D or any
any kind of weird telepathy I think it's
there's a there's a moment that you
share when you're when you're deep in
thought with someone where you're both
you're not even thinking about the
present position right you're both
thinking about plans and you're
countering each other and so you almost
just sort of take for granted what's in
front of you and it happens rarely that
players of this level would miss it but
it does happen and and it's uh it's not
that abnormal so
yeah all right
we've got we've got a tide match
man for five unicorn wanna fans they
breathe a sigh of relief because if he
didn't get that one he had problems
that's true and we're repeating this
position now which I'm I'm not sure
whose decision it was because I I didn't
quite catch you know where certain
players deviated or stayed the same but
yeah it seems to me like this is more of
a decision that uh Fabi would would take
so interesting he's totally comfortable
playing this again
well it's funny you and I liked his
position just before Notre big got the
Queens off the board remember we were
saying black got what if you wanted the
opening let's let's analyze again
because we're here might as well show
everybody Queen to E7 was played in the
previous game white wins back the pawn
and the point of this line is white is
up a pawn but has permanently sacrificed
light Square protection we already had a
game where Fabiano eventually got
compensation but then let the Queens
come off the board so that's that's what
Amman is referring to and and by the way
we're getting maybe a similar idea now
I think so and it it's it's also the
case that this is the way that black is
used to playing this position so
one way or another he's going to want to
get back to that territory where you've
got the the weaknesses on the king side
and now that White's played the move A3
it's also much weaker on the queen side
so Rook on V8 hold that pawn on B2 there
for basically the rest of the game
yep
Rook gonna be eight holds B2 in some
cases when the D file becomes open you
get pressure here because as Ammon
pointed out white can never really
protect this Pawn with the easy move E3
as you would in any other position
because the moment you do that you
really have wrist the light squares and
so if you just use your imagination
white takes the pawn here black has all
kinds of pressure and white is
struggling for moves because of just how
dangerous it okay we might see it
because of just how dangerous these
light squares can be so
um
and note that Bobby goes for he could
have actually taken C4 and gone to
immediately the optical Bishop ending
but he wants that middle game he wants
his chances on the diagonal yeah I think
a lot of times you can play this
position with black really unambitiously
where you just play down upon an
opposite Bishop position
I think in a speed chess match that's
actually a really poor strategy because
you're just handing only chances in the
position to your opponent that doesn't
feel good so it makes more sense even
the circumstances he wants to play a
position with the Queen's on
yeah computer didn't like Queen C3
because uh well let's just be honest
computers are greedy right and uh but I
can understand notorbeck's decision to
not want to open that deck anyone
looking at this in chat knows what it's
like to lose a game to a Checkmate
attack and so we're not gonna We're not
gonna pass judgment to Notre back for
not taking the pawn
right and he's got pressure now on E2
um so I think Fabi has a lot of a lot of
options here because you mentioned the
worst type of move to play is E3 and
he's trying to bait that move out he's
putting enough pressure he's saying
please play E3 you keep your extra Pawn
but I get all the pressure
and now black has a decision do I try to
defend E6 whether it's rookie sorry C6
with Rook E6 or Rook C8 or do I get rid
of that pawn with Bishop takes E2 but
allow Queen takes C6 I
you know I trust Mr carwana is uh
probably played this session before but
look at that it shows he wants that
practical Edge I'm on he's not trying to
get the pieces off the board he wants to
keep playing this
totally and there's going to be pressure
on E2 my white husband was like Rook C2
to watch over that but black can also
just stick the bishop on B5 play A4 and
bring the Rook to the middle of the
board and it's just all in on the E2
Pawn
desperately wants those Queens off
because he's worried about long-term
Checkmate problems
this will be a funny moment Fabiano
going to avoid the queen trade again I
expect whether he whether he takes B2 or
finds somewhere else I don't think he
wants the Queens off the board
okay well I I'm gonna get out of here
I don't know
uh I think he would have done something
different if you had suggested something
different like he was going to do the
opposite of whatever you suggested no
matter what it's exactly because they're
just they're baiting chat but if Bobby's
like look at this Danny's predicting no
Queen trade take that feature chat all
right well Jokes Aside
in hindsight I guess it makes a lot of
sense because in this case Amman he was
able to steal the pawn without taking
more pieces off the board there's no
trade and so what's funny is the Queens
are off the boredom on but in this case
that doesn't mean that white is totally
out of light square danger that's right
yeah it's it's kind of an uncomfortable
feeling also King G2 or something here
does actually lose material I love that
ship F3 and Bishop G2 so
um yeah actually what we might get here
I was looking at the move A4 I'm not
sure how much sense that makes but it
has the uh a nice idea of stopping
Bishop B5 which is Black's guaranteed
strong defensive resource a monstradamus
someone said nostrils Dom and
Nostradamus sarcastically making fun of
me I'm gonna call you a monster a
monster a monster Dominus a monster
domes anyway
um that's a great move you have to say
it five times every time yeah five times
it doesn't go but a month's point is
really good sometimes the best move chat
is you don't have a great plan but you
prevent your opponent from establishing
the ideal position and A4 really did
that so that was a good call out him on
but I'm gonna I'm gonna say that despite
the eval bar liking white from a
practical perspective I don't think
Fabiano has lost all of his Prussian
pressuring chances here no but uh I
guess the only point to I guess sort of
to the contrary is that we may get into
a similar situation that we had in a
previous game where I believe that Fabi
might start to get slightly optimistic
about his chances and we may see an Apon
from order back run up the board again
so I feel it feels like it's a repeat
Battle of what we we just had
and Bishop C7 is a great move
highlighting the other secondary purpose
of A4 not just to hold B5 but to make
sure that pawn was dead where he stands
and Bishop to C7 is a really nice move
from Notre back suddenly Fabiano has to
use his one minute time advantage
okay I like this move I just I you know
what I got made on the brain I'm on you
know what I'm talking about you know
come on yeah I mean I know that F4 can
be played here but I wouldn't even
underestimate the move F3 it looks like
really silly to just give up a pawn but
your king then has enough air that
you're not going to be getting mated for
sure and I feel a little uncomfortable
allowing Bishop F3 with the F on on F2
okay I feel you
will Notre back free the king or laugh
in the face of danger he answers it
before I can complete my anecdotal
unnecessary pop culture reference he
does laugh in the face of danger look at
this Iman he just says I'm just gonna
take the pawn where's the mate like I
got the battery covered yeah that's
actually great uh Arrow you just
highlighted Bishop F3 Rook C5 to C1 and
it's like okay I get it you know you got
lots of pressure but if I leave a rook
on the back rank there will never be
mate
yeah
fascinating and gutsy
but that's how uh that's how Jess games
were won at this level you can't miss
your opportunities
and Notre back goes for it look at this
move G5 though he's going for the long
term chances now and Monty's like look I
might be down two pawns but I'm gonna
get G4 I'm gonna make sure you will
never escape on the light squares and I
will be poking at Checkmate from now
until Kingdom Come
and you know ultimately that a pawn for
white should not really get past A5
that's fair that's a really good point
actually yeah okay he's got the bishop
retreating
so so look this is a different idea it
wants to undermine the D5 Pawn Maybe yep
I'm just saying okay like I'll bring my
king into H3 and that's why it's so
reminiscent of their previous game where
Abby's letting the queen side just go
and meanwhile he's got this sort of
aggressive plan where I'm not sure if
Abby's even ready to admit that he's not
playing for a win yeah it's crazy and
again that's where we're you know we
have the eval bar and and it's good
stuff it it helps us see big blunders
and gives us context but make no mistake
this position is not equal for both
sides in terms of how hard it is to play
there's a very dangerous position here
for white I think that Notre back knows
what he's doing but this bishop is a
thorn it guards everything and look at
the black king it's like the computer is
fine with white but I'm loving Black's
chances here
totally and that as I said that Apon is
not going past A5 so it's really just
kind of a dead end situation
dude look at now he's bringing the Rook
to F6 and it's funny because I I don't
want to go on on a speech or tangent
here even though I have a fun story to
tell because I want to stay in the
moment but this does remind me a little
bit Iman of what Fabi said at the world
championship commentary for 2021 where
he said we go for positions where
someone has a small advantage and they
think that it they can play it but we
know that it's very playable and long
term black is now out playing white from
what
Bobby owner just did it just just
outplayed white from an equal position
as black yep and uh this this is why I
was saying I don't disagree with fabi's
decision earlier in the match to play on
yeah I didn't disagree with it it's just
that the execution was there from
nordeback he is able to find insane
moves under time pressure but he's not
gonna be able to do that every single
game and if he is power to him
and look at I mean look at this position
we were already calling it forget what
the eval Bar says this points out from
every practical perspective the moment
the king went to E4 you were watching
you saw our excitement we were like oh
my God the black king is coming in there
are problems and carwana converts the
dub from what a lot of fans would say oh
how did white lose that it was an
obstacle Bishop position but not so not
so fair to say that that was a very
difficult game for white and back to the
point for anyone who doesn't know that
story Fabiano talked about preparation
at the highest of highest levels and he
said these days with computers you know
you can hold a lot of positions and a
lot of times the biggest advantages you
get and Magnus does this well too Amon
is going for positions where you know
you're giving your opponent a little bit
of an edge but you've looked so deeply
in the position that you either know
it's safe or you know there's a lot more
opportunities for them to go wrong than
they think and you hope to catch your
opponent choosing lines like that where
they're underestimating how hard it is
to play because objectively they're like
oh the computer said it was equal but
but you went deeper yep that's a great
point
anyway it's Danny this is a what a what
a treat everyone's favorite exciting
opening the London system
if I could I would delete the London
from chess did I just just reveal my
feelings right there like you would you
you'd press the button
I would update the system
courtesy of our of our presenting
sponsor coinbase I would update the
system and in the new system ampissant
on every move is forced if you have it
it's forced and the London no longer
exists
wow so does that mean like D4 Bishop F4
is unplayable or does that mean that we
go back to an age where it wasn't
discovered yet and we wait to see who
discovers it first
now that's fascinating I kind of thought
the former I thought it was like you're
just not allowed to play it like you try
and it just doesn't allow you because I
see what you're doing you're giving me
an opportunity to find it and name it
the Iman Hamilton system I see where hey
I I go for that too
was forced by the way that would
actually be funny because now up assumpt
becomes a trap if you ever get your Pawn
in a bad spot like you could be trapped
into half and into playing on passant I
think that's actually an interesting
variant to consider's forced yep yep
okay all right here we go we're back at
it our thoughts there yeah
we've uh we've got Bishop G3 but Jokes
Aside the London is actually a very good
Blitz weapon and it's a system that by
Design if you can get a structure that
you know better than your opponent Here
Comes you know here comes tactics where
they can blunder maybe positions where
they get under time pressure I'm on you
know this position much better than me
so tell me tell me how much you like
white hair uh all right Danny if you
want to pull up an analysis for it I'll
I'll give you my my uh thoughts on the
London here
um
commence let's go before Bishop G3 uh
there's one one idea which I really like
which is when you're faced with this
type of situation especially with a
bishop on D7 because that means the
Knight on F6 can't Retreat to D7 you
take the bishop on D6 you play 95 and
your next move is F4 and you play in a
fun stone wall really quickly the bishop
D3 uh Queen F3 G4 G5 castle kingside and
black has a hard time like moving the
Knight on F6 and playing on to F6
himself and any Knight C6 you're just
hitting him with F4 you don't care so
I've had a lot of success playing these
types of positions
um so I think that's maybe something you
could have gone for but uh Fabi went for
a really sort of a mainstream approach
like Bishop G3 is like classic
um and then Bishop D3 I think he
followed up with
oh I love that idea so there you go
quick little London analysis a little
knowledge nugget put it in your pocket
spend it at the next chess bra stream
you're watching
um subscribe to the chess bras today
I'm on the London specialist Hamilton I
couldn't agree more
um the way that I would play Bishop D6
and 95 here Danny like it would just be
Quick Draw McGraw like you wouldn't even
let me ask this for someone who wants to
learn asking for a friend
is it is it bad to play 95 before Bishop
D6 like what what is the is it just
because white white can get kicked out
with F6 eventually or why is it 95 and
keep the bishop on the board an option
uh I think both are viable definitely so
95 there and then Pawn F4 would be nice
you give the extra option of Bishop H4
for yourself
um but you also block your g-pawn so
like your attack uh gets going a little
bit uh slower but no I wouldn't ever
classify those as like you definitely do
one and not the other I think players
just develop a preference based on their
experience so I think both are good
options
so what's this bishop H4 move he didn't
go for the Iman Hamilton shake and bake
on D6 and pop the pony he's keeping all
the pieces on the board
this is yeah it's kind of interesting
because there's no Knight D7 to protect
the Knight that's right and I think he
would Thrive if black played a move like
Bishop E7
um the reason why I'm not sure Bishop H4
is is that good I mean it's a good move
but not like anything too crazy is
because of exactly what you're seeing
where Black's like yeah give me G takes
F6 I actually don't mind this position
so I'm excited to see the imbalance play
out here Danny because White's looking
at things like Knight H4 clean out
immediately and meanwhile black has the
dark squares all under his control so if
blackhead you know succumb to the
pressure and thought Oh I have to defend
F6 Bishop E7 it would have seen 95 F4
and it would have been like a really
nasty position
I love that really instructive stuff
here so black has the dark squares black
has clear plans of how you want to
undermine this but white has the open
King and the long-term attacking chances
I'm I'm with you though the more I look
at it the more I'm liking the exchange
for black and here goes the computer
kind of slightly favoring the second
player yep so uh that's why I don't
really love this bishop takes F6 thing
you think that it's like a thread
because you're doubling the Pawns in
front of the king you're exposing it but
actually Black's happy to go King h8 and
Rook G8 and you know maybe even a
different plan C4 and pawn to F5 is
another common way to play this position
for black
yeah talk about some light Square
problems white will have a lot of them
if black gets and here goes Notre back
not waiting to be asked for permission
look at this light squares can I
highlight it before he does it hold on
go Danny go go oh there's one Pawn I
went as fast as I could
well I don't think he's going to be
playing A6 so we might not get them all
in light squares but uh I can't
sugarcoat this this is not a good
position for white it's it's not the end
of the world there's play for white here
but black is completely happy with the
outcome of the opening and I I don't
think this is any real try for what
so not a successful attempt for the
London as much as it pains me to admit
it
just kidding I can hear you laughing
already exactly no no but it is
instructive nonetheless especially
because you highlighted maybe maybe the
ways that white should have played it
differently earlier look at this turn
around right black black is now using
the G file
using the the diagonals and white is
back to sort of positionally hoping for
some space by undermining the queen side
not not your everyday London
that's right I will say I think this
position for white is worse over the
board than it is in Blitz because
White's position is so solid like true
truly everything defends everything you
don't have any weak points
um so sometimes it's just really hard
for black to
undermine your your setup if black plays
E5 all of a sudden the AF pawns and the
d-pawn is super weak so black also
doesn't have like easy easy ways to
progress but you know if you have a lot
of time to play this position or In
classical I feel like you feel a little
bit helpless this way
yeah that makes sense the grind is a lot
easier when you have a ton of time for
black and you just ensure you keep the
grip but I think from a blitz
perspective it's much closer seeing the
uh the way that the path of the game
followed you go back there you see
Black's Edge dip down the moment he
didn't follow him on Hamilton's advice
and he went for this bishop H4 Bishop
takes F6 idea we're gonna rename that
eval graph to the Iman the um the Iman
meter the Ammon meter
it's it's a wonder that name hasn't
caught on already it just rolls off
let's add an oh whenever you add an O it
rolls up a manometer and rolls off the
tongue a little easier
no okay
the amount of meter we check in with the
a monometer everyone and um and uh black
is better ever since white didn't follow
the right idea but here goes Rook B7
yeah this is kind of a I like if white
just trades things off I feel like he's
not going to be significantly worse in
any kind of end game black will be I
believe that black will be better with
the Bishops and more space and the weak
Pawn on C3 but you know white just has
these creative ways to defend everything
like Knight B1 like Knight F4 to E2 I
just feel like right you're not gonna be
able to attack things enough
so despite the eval bar despite the
amount of meter look at this from now on
when we talk about the a monometer I'm
gonna do that
oh look at that
look at that can someone Photoshop a
man's face right where the the black
Advantage started that would be super
fantastic for me put the Amon emote
right there for the amanometer to live
all right I'm sorry I'll I'll stop now
okay all over the place there
um all right but note that White's
Advantage has now kind of come back you
called it right you said over the board
this is easier for black to convert and
Blitz often black will let the grip slip
and here Fabi is back to just a very
solid position
yeah it's
I don't really know how to describe it
but uh basically I don't think that Fabi
is risking a lot here I also don't think
that Norbeck is risking a lot but fabi's
position I didn't like so I think he's
more of an achievement for him to be
like okay here
right
in Blitz it's funny because this isn't
this isn't going to stay this way at
some point we probably get even worse
time pressure King to G6 is played
what's what is black doing I mean he's
walking his King into D I would not
trade yeah Queen C2 he doesn't want to
look at this
yeah
look at that yeah he did not need to
play King G6
Knight F4 he was expecting almost like
white to repeat there and he's a little
shocked to find that's not the case
and we highlight the move that turned
the amount of meter around it was King
to G6 and White's Advantage started to
go back the other direction noterbeck
has gotten himself in trouble here
this is a bad position now this is just
questionable Knight F3 nearly threatens
some weird check hey Judy does it 9h4
and like we're about to get in puzzle
Rush territory where it's a lot of those
weird positions and there's a weird mate
yep
and this is two seconds it's gonna be
very strange because Black's Queen
pretty much doesn't exist
dude speaking of puzzle brush there's a
force mate with Knight H4 and G5 check
and F4 I saw it before you played it
Bobby oh he missed it dude G5 and F4 was
forced mate
oh but he went on time okay I see I see
but the F4 at least was still a great
move but Danny was not as good as your
move okay okay thank you for saying that
but all that matters is that Fabiano
caruana has a two-game lead and if
you're just tuning in
the opposite was the case before the
break and my partner here said that
sometimes the break can really hurt the
player who has momentum and a monstrous
Thomas strikes again because Notre Beck
has not won since we returned from
halftime a month
that's that's true actually so some uh
some truth to that Danny I also noticed
that uh Fabi has only one since you uh
coined the term a monometer so just so
many things to pay attention to here
and by the way Fabiano going back to the
well that seems to be uh
giving him all the drinks he wants uh
again the the opening battle today has
been that carwana has refused to switch
away from this black side uh position
against the Catalan it's a consistent
choice to sacrifice a pawn but to get
the long-term compensation on the light
squares I'm just highlighting for
everyone the storyline of this position
real quick and we've seen this played
several times and it's funny even though
Fabiano lost the time scramble Amman
said it then that he didn't he didn't
you know uh he didn't doubt the choice
bite by Fabi to go for the type of
position though and he continues to go
for it
absolutely
um if I'm really stepping back and
thinking about this match
um
like I I actually don't think that Fabi
has made too many mistakes in terms of
the quality of his his chess um he's
missed a few things like maybe that of
course made sequence at the end but did
he need to see it he also missed a free
night but to be fair it wasn't like he
missed it in blunders he just he just
didn't see it and he didn't see a fork
of a queen and Rook earlier in the match
as well right but he never like threw
his Advantage away he still had a good
position so his misses haven't cost him
anything it just haven't gotten him
anything whereas yeah nordeback has been
down on time he's spoiled some positions
in time pressure he's been blundering
pieces I feel like the mistakes that
nordeback is making are are probably
ones that he's thinking about more uh
that he's more conscious of and that
cost him
I couldn't agree more and not to toot
our own horn but we we are often wrong
so highlighting when we're right we were
saying it Chad that even though Bobby
was down again we were kind of like
Bobby seems on form today right we felt
it in his moves and even though he lost
that game in time pressure whatever as
he as he has righted the ship here
especially maybe maybe with that break
helping him calm down
um I agree right now it is Notre Dix
ship to kind of turn around he's down
two games and he hasn't solved this nut
here this uh this position is giving him
fits Fabiano gonna keep going for it
yeah that's the thing when you find
something that works just stylistically
against your your opponent giving them
that situation you're just gonna keep
hammering it right over and over again
once again I mean maybe there's other
moves but Knight takes C3 how do you not
play this move and how are you not
comfortable with black if anything I
almost play for the advantage with the
black pieces you can set up Pawn F6 Pawn
E5 uh Bishop D5 to C4 yeah Rook B8 Rook
d8 I mean I feel like you're the you're
the one uh pressing here
C4 is explosive
um oh that was an accident oh I can't
get the bomb away hold on how do I okay
I'm sorry turning the bomb off
it's gone
oh sorry but C4 is explosive what an
idea if you plant the bishop on that
because the point is not only is it an
outpost square there's no Pawn that can
attack it but it actually sits in a
really thorny spot because black also I
mean black is dominating both sides of
the board from that square and white
can't even can't even get a rook to
attack it so I love this idea of
bringing the bishop in maybe even this
way as well they both work
yep
um pawns on the same color as your
opponent's Bishop is
um the way to play an opposite Bishop
position
um the only time you'll you'll really
want to put them on the opposite color
of your opponent's Bishop so the same
color as your own is if maybe you're on
the
maybe you're down upon or you're on the
defensive side of an end game and you're
just trying to make a draw but if you
have any ambition for more than a draw
they need to be probably on the same
color
instructive stuff just pouring out of
them on Hamilton right now he can't even
keep it in just like he walks in and
just like knowledge is just dropping out
of his pockets without anything that he
says it's um it's get it's getting it's
a tough uh you know across to Bear Danny
it's a tough cross to bear but no really
good stuff highlighting just how
dysfunctional this is that White's
pieces are are less active Fabi not even
in a rush to maybe improve The Bishop's
diagonal because that square is going
nowhere
um
the only thing I would worry about is
you don't want to give up the chance to
to get the file to so at some point the
ideal position for black is the bishop
here a rook on this file this Rook
already dominates this file and white is
Frozen
yep and Bishop C6 is I mean obviously
Fabi can do no wrong here
um but slightly less ambitious yeah uh
shall we say than getting the bishop to
C4 uh nevertheless every square is
covered B4 D4 D5 D5 B6 D6 right you see
how every single entry Square for white
is covered on the B and D files so Fabi
doesn't mind giving up one of those
files and look he's safe to swear for
his King what a guy dude the moment he
played that I was like oh
oh he wanted the king there
what a guy as you said that is a fun
idea
I love that we might be just
experiencing an SCC Master Class of
obstacode Bishops today everyone if you
want to just buckle up pull the seat
belt tight right for turbulence you are
about to be a part of a of an SEC
someone should watch this five minute
portion again because what a fascinating
way to learn that just because it's
equal doesn't mean that you can't play
on and the opposite color Square
dominance by carwana has already won him
two games in this line
and I this is just so instructive to see
black pushing pushing these positions on
Rook takes B3 because hey why would you
not want to guard your Pawn
and I think you get into the territory
of A4 Brook A3 and well oops you're
never going to move your Rook again for
the rest of the game uh and if you don't
go to A3 well then you lose the uh C
Pawn so I think he actually made the
best decision he takes B3 but what a
tough spot to be in where you need to
give up on
it's amazing amazing what an interesting
line a bit of a lesson note Rebecca do
satoroff might be learning um from
Fabiano caruana as far as his choice in
the Catalan again if this match stays on
because right now
either Notre back is going to have to go
away from this line I'm on or Just
Surrender that it will be black playing
for a win if he keeps going for this
black is just dominating this line
totally and as you're saying that out
loud I mean there's only one logical way
to proceed he's got to change
yeah
okay Fabi is is gonna accept equality I
guess it's a victory given that he's uh
it doesn't mean he's giving up a draw
I'm saying like he's not going for
anything crazy here
and he's actually gonna get the white
pieces to see for one more game right
yeah he'll get the white pieces with one
minute left that was really interesting
I wasn't I wasn't thinking that a mom
but that's exactly what he was doing he
wanted to get one more opportunity to
strike it Notre back
I mean Fabio has been
like so cool about this position with
black he's he's held it uh he's pushed
for a win
um I think that nordeback now gets to
evaluate whether or not he wants to play
another five minute games he's answering
it he's answering right look at the
games with chip Everybody Take note
notorbeck recognizes he's like why did
Fabiano give up his pressure oh he
wanted one more chance with the white
pieces and I feel like we just haven't
pointed it out yet for the fans who
don't know look above five in four car
one there's a clock ticking down that
means 30 seconds remain before we end
the five minute portion and we head to
three minute chess and that shows you
the meta that these guys are coming in
with here Fabiana wants every chance he
can to get a win in the longer time
controls against Notre Beck and Notre
back is like I'm tired of this
proverbial bleep let's head let's head
to some three minutes yes
totally and I think both players had a a
pretty good idea like Bobby getting
another game with white great and even
Fabby making a draw here it's not like
the position was winning and he like you
know threw it all away for a draw no
like he could maybe push it but it
wasn't winning on the board so he's just
making a decision and saying look like
this is totally fine for me I'm holding
with black I'm up in the match yeah I'll
make a draw and go to three minutes
and the moment it is secured that he
doesn't have to play another five minute
game Notre back moves to Pieces we have
a draw and we will head to the faster
portion with Fabiano caruana of five to
three in the scoreboard I love that
content I love this features
Championship I love you Fabiano caruana
and I love your fro look at that
close-up look at the man
love that guys that he can't hear you
come on your thoughts on the two-game
lead Bobby on a carwana has
I actually think that this is one of the
first times where going into the break I
can safely say that I think both players
are content obviously you're not content
being down in the match if you're not
about but I think you're content to be
out of the five minute portion and be
able to re-evaluate the the variations
that you're going for I don't think we
will see that variation of Catalan again
Danny from nordbeck be very surprised we
do if we do he has a new idea that he
wants to show because Fabi has just not
decimated that line in chess but for
this match he's killed it I think so
um you definitely need to switch that up
if you're not back and it's Fabby you're
up too after being down one I mean you
got to be in a good mood yeah
instructive stuff there and instructive
opening Choice car one is up two games
and uh we're loving it
and if you love the speeches
Championship we know you're loving it
okay we're all loving it we love our
sponsor coinbase as well quick shout out
to them it's the crypto platform that's
revolutionizing it's changing the game
and it's time for you to update your
financial systems uh I want to update
chess and delete the London make an
office on Force I got all kinds of ideas
for the a monometer some of them PG some
of them not I'm just going to be honest
with what I want to do with the a
monometer but either way you need to go
to coinbase.com update the system today
check it out if you're not using
coinbase for any and all of your crypto
needs then you're making a mistake
you know it would also be a mistake I'm
on
um okay we're thinking of things other
than playing the London yeah no go ahead
changing the channel because we are in
for a thriller Fabiano caruana has a
two-game lead he's Iman Hamilton he's
bringing the knowledge don't go anywhere
the 2023 speed Chess Championship
presented by coinbase returns in a few
[Music]
foreign
Bots are here and it's time for a
Monumental Clash
Barbarian might not Crush you on the
board but he certainly can Crush you
with the board
thinking of crushing this giant is a
living Siege Tower usually found in
groups goblins are fond of sharp pointy
objects and other people's pieces
the battleheart in Valkyrie might give
you a game once she's done arm wrestling
a Golem
this hog rider and his Noble Steed might
give you a headache or two skeletons
adore her those fear her you'll need to
bring your A game if you want to be this
witch yes that probably is a rabbit up
his sleeve or a huge Fireball with your
name on it we hear Wizards are pretty
good at chess
not just a killing machine Pekka loves
tiny butterflies but you're probably not
a butterfly so watch out
the Archer Queen thinks highly of
herself and for good reason she is a
skilled tactician deadly opponent and
your worst nightmare lay them all on
chess.com
but she's not gonna move it because it's
defended oh she did it
we need a compilation chest.com social
media crew look through the park Champs
games
[Music]
how many times I called the moon
okay 11. you asked for it here we go
it's almost a Salesman knows what he's
doing he's gonna try to Andrea Andrea
there's a stalemate coming Pawn here
take King G4 he pushes and it's a
stalemate oh my goodness well you
clearly I'm sure you taught Frank about
stalemate no okay
[Applause]
this I blame you for all of this this is
oh my goodness
Bishop takes Pawn takes Queen takes
loses the bishop and if that happens I
will be heartbroken because you could
have just
that was your heart heavy
is it feeling okay
her heart how is it you can't even
script this stuff my man
okay okay
[Music]
his position is is hard to lose as long
as it stays how it is
yeah for sure
unless he starts going totally crazy
with something like Ponte G
what is your ability today you literally
said that in real time
[Music]
thank you
the 2023 speed Chess Championship rolls
on presented by coinbase Iman Hamilton
is here presenting the Amada meter TM
now brought to you every time he does
commentary maybe even when you're not
around I'm going to talk about it
that would be that would be nice just a
reminder Danny that I'm I'm always there
I'm always looking you're always there
the amount of mirror it just rolls off
the tongue you know what else rolls off
the tongue the pedigree the career that
this young man notarbeck abdusatorov has
had him on Hamilton take us through your
favorite fave highlights
yeah honestly I think uh the moment
where I really became not only aware but
also just a fan of nordeback's Chess was
at the Olympiad in 2022. for me that was
a breakout performance for him bold
medalist or Uzbekistan uh the T the team
obviously was you know full of
star-studded players but they were all
young it all had something to prove and
no one expected them to pull off that
performance so you know quite a list of
achievements there the world rapid
Champion is not to be uh not to be
glossed over Danny but for me his
Olympiad performance leading his team
against the best players in the world
was where he became fully on the map for
me well you talked about how scary he is
online he puts his hands on his face
let's talk about how scary he is over
the board with this awesome looking to
this Tata steel uh Masters and Blitz
that just took place in India shout out
to Robert Hess who was there when
Kolkata but look at him stare down Hari
Krishna before entering the blitz beast
mode and she's converting with ruthless
Precision this King upon ending look at
that he calculated it out he went for it
got the job done dudes a beast I mean
the thing about that end game is it was
probably winning but even if it wasn't
winning he might be able to win it just
from the stair alone like I wouldn't
wouldn't put it past the Harry Krishna
to just blunder after being stared down
like that
and there he is back at his board right
now he's a little nervous let's be
honest he's down two games to Fabiano
caruana as we head into this three
minute portion if you don't know the
speeches championship format you go from
five minutes to three minutes ultimately
to Bullet so who will prove to be the
better player in this middle time
control the one that tends to be the
back breaker sometimes I'm on because
you don't want to be down too many games
heading into bullet no matter who you
are and uh there's Fabiano feeling
pretty fresh
yeah I'm just gonna go back and
highlight that Abby's biggest mistake
today and perhaps his only one uh you
know apart from maybe missing
opportunities to better his position
which he didn't take but you know he
didn't actually commit any errors it's
only been overpressing so I mean I'm
sorry but how do you win a match against
someone whose biggest problem is pushing
too hard uh when they when they thought
they had an advantage I mean if Fabi
doesn't start making some serious
mistakes like getting low on time actual
blunders he hasn't made any significant
ones this match it's just a hard match
to win uh Danny what are you supposed to
do
yeah I agree and and again just to
repeat the point I'm on quickly made and
for those who missed the early stages of
this match
arguably the only victories notabeck has
gotten right now were ones where Fabiano
kind of pushed you hard right he had
that game he had no business losing in
the obstacle Bishop ending so so Notre
pick has not really arrived yet and or
you give Fabiano Carr want a credit for
the openings he's chosen keeping Notre
back off balance and uh yeah you're
right he's got to figure it out
and certainly in an orthodox position
here they actually repeated that London
line and if there's one player who
definitely improved things it was
nordeback you'll notice that he did not
play that move Bishop D6 that yeah I was
so ready for Bishop takes D6 for last
time now he instead took on D4 quickly
played Bishop B5 traded light Square
Bishops White's Kings on F1 incredibly
different position for black
yeah when we had the analysis board I
might quickly back up and show that
because it is instructive and it's also
reaffirming that Notre back is not going
to waste his breaks if you're just
tuning in again I hate that I'm just
saying that but another big storyline we
had is that even though the momentum has
turned Karma on its way since the break
we had in five minute Notre deck did
double check the opening where he got a
bad position against Bobby and right at
the ship and here now that we can bring
up the analysis board I'll quickly show
oman's point was that up till this move
seven we were in the same London game
where Fabiano got a great a great
position but instead of playing Bishop
to D6 which is what notorbeck played the
first time he improves by capturing on
D4 and eliminating the light Square
Bishops which is perhaps the best way
for black to play this position so
really good point of on that that Notre
back is improving at least he's using
his brakes wisely
is and you know Norbeck is not someone
who I think lets his emotions gets the
the get the better of him I I think that
he's using his brakes well as you said I
don't think that he's on tilt I think
he's just up against Fabi who is on form
today and to be honest he's just having
a tough time but I really don't think
that he's played in in such a way where
it's like oh he's getting destroyed this
match that's not the feeling I get I
just get the feeling Abby is playing so
well right now I I couldn't agree more
and we see the real-time chat vote of
who will win today that is the combined
percentages of people voting on both
twitch and YouTube we love you both
twitch and YouTube so you can stop the
feud twitch and YouTube if you're out
there stop the feud just play chess
everyone you love them both Danny but we
love the vote equally yep
I mean I do have a favorite just like
with my kids I'm not going to say which
one on camera of course but you'll tell
each of them separately I'll tell each
of them separately but it's definitely
Hazel just kidding no
um the uh the you don't have a favorite
but we do combine all the voters on
Twitch and YouTube so play along with us
keep keep the good comments coming in
and we'll get them featured for you
all right here we go um one thing about
this structure it's actually uh
transformed a lot since uh the beginning
but one thing that has not changed is
that a knight on D3 and a knight on D6
are white in for black in this sort of
like unstructure this Call Carl's bad
reverse Carlsbad looking structure is
always going to be well placed pieced uh
it guards P2 for white it's the B4 C5 E5
and F4 squares just so so useful and the
same thing can be said for black with a
knight on D6 uh so those are just very
operative squares and I feel like if
you're not familiar with the structure
you won't know to put the knights there
uh but both of these guys keenly aware
and that's why you see all these nice
just kind of zigzagging jumping around
they're trying to reach the best
possible
yep I can't even highlight them fast
enough as they shuttle their Knights to
the best squares
it is a minority attack structure and
again to highlight what it is it's a
reverse Carlsbad as Oman said meaning
you have two pawns versus three but by
definition whenever you have a minority
meaning you have two and they have three
you also have open files and so black
has the pressure against the pawns black
would like to convert said pressure into
something real but you're also you have
less pawns and so white white is kind of
trying to keep an eye on these pawns
also try to use the majority they have
Here Comes This Knight to C5 which I
actually I love that spot interesting
little find
I think he's always going to be okay
with you know something to the effect of
you take my Apon and I hopefully get
your B part um if you're if you're not a
bad and because the end of that means
the C Pawn is weaker sorry just
continuing the full translation of my
grand master partner here the reason
black is happy with that is these trades
mean this is weak okay now this is a
risky move in the structure I'm on
because E5 always undermines your Pawn
chain and Fabi doesn't have to be asked
to poke at this guy
absolutely E4 is nearly forced there
because of what you just brought up
um yeah and I guess interestingly H5 and
F5 are both covered so white can't
continue to attack yeah the D5 Pawn
which is quite helpful Queen F4 looks
like a reasonable Tempo to grab on the
Knight on D6 which uh by the way there
was a hanging Knight on D6 earlier this
match
what a game that was that was wild that
was so funny
um
yeah okay but this time this time Notre
break doesn't hang his Knight on D6 but
he does have to give up the F5 Square
after moving the Knight and look at Fabi
how often does the queen approve herself
Amman with one square at a time well
sometimes it happens and here there's a
lot of pressure to deal with
there is you have Rook V8 like a you
know move to just watch over that pawn
you feel like everything is covered for
black but also that everything's hanging
by a thread because the Knight on V6
Rook A8 Queen E8 are all needed to watch
the a pawn the Knight B6 Rook d8 are all
needed to watch the Deep on and so it's
just positions like this where he's
hanging by a thread I don't know they
can be very risky yeah
so far Notre back is holding on but
quick shout out to for the first time to
the to the time control B3 was a blunder
Fabiano thinks he can do this but it
actually doesn't work black can actually
just take and give up the rook in
notorbeck season
oh my God what a blunder amazing thing
is King F7 Knight d8 Rook takes d8
that's that's one uh key detail because
it almost Knight d8 would save the night
in some ways you could see maybe it
happened but Rook tasty is a huge move
it's crazy and look at Bobby he did a
little bit of a wait what and we see the
a monometer drop big time on that move
B3 black is better I'm on Hamilton
strikes again what did I say about fatty
I was like if he doesn't blunder this
match like Good Luck winning it he's
going out there's gonna have to be a
mistake and he finally does commit a
mistake can black capitalize
according to the computer this is a
mistake it allows Rook B7 check and if
you take white gets Knight C5 and Knight
A4 I think is the idea
but that's a very hard thing to see if
Fabiano finds that with no time oh my
God he's finding it
Fabiano finds that with no time then
Fabiano caruana I mean that's just stuff
that he does
what an idea here
time scramble time as Chad says indeed
but I think we're we're back in a spot
where white has very good drawing
chances
yeah but there's only one person playing
uh for a result here and I think what
you might be able to achieve because I
don't think you can keep the d-pawn for
white like let's say black wants it he
can get it but he's gonna have to give
up upon let's say on H6 and this is
exactly what we're seeing
yeah but the right idea from notrec for
sure you can push on for a win if you
win that d-pawn you have a pass Pawn but
all right no time left here in the first
game of the three minute portion both
players living on the increment
yeah this this is a really really good
attempt here from from norterbeck like
he's trying his best
wow what a move and then he finds F3
Fabiano recognizes active defense and
just like that the table base when that
happens ladies and gentlemen that means
the table base confirms this is a draw
now that does not mean it's going to be
a draw because if there's a blunder It's
Gonna Change no longer will it be a gray
drawn position yep
yeah and he's gonna leave the King on G2
and
yeah there's not
not really any worry unless it gets the
territory where you because the thing is
Black's gonna try to move that pawn down
the board right down to F3 but
I'm not sure that it's actually enough
space to do this F3 Rook H1 trick it's
not which is amazing that Fabiano holds
that I would have died in that position
trying to hold the pawn and not
recognized wait but he does wonder you
can take it
the king and pawn ending but on over he
could have taken the pawn that's what I
meant like King takes F3 and Rook F1
check is not enough space because King
E2
oh my God we got to bring up the
analysis board that was that was crazy
instructive I just learned something big
time and unfortunately for Fabiano so
did he
the reason this whole trick doesn't work
is because normally you can never take
everyone because when you make a move
like this normally there's a check and
then a queen but in this case the king
is close enough as Oman said and so
there is no check white gets there in
time instead fobby blunders the classic
backdoor Rook trick where you where you
skewer the king and Rook on the back
door
he was thinking to himself oh I know
about the trick with King takes F3 let
me play King F2
whereas
he actually needed to be aware of the
trick with King F2 and play King takes
F3 right okay wow we come back to the
live game and good news for Notre back
fans as I as I bring up the live game
here my apologies for that
um
is uh
this time the break favors the kid I'm
on
um I'm just going to say the same thing
Danny I think you're spot on with that
uh it's been a real like match Turner uh
every single time now the break has
really helped one of the players and we
haven't seen Fabi make that many
mistakes in the whole match and they all
appear in one game
yeah I'm sitting here like wow that's
that's really a mind-blowing
mind-blowing moment and if Notre Beck
abdusa turov comes back to win this
match that will be a game we remember as
a huge momentum Turner the first game of
the three meter portion so here you go
Fabiana Karma
no longer gets the black side of that
Catalan but who changed first I'm on I
was focused on The Rook ending
instruction it looks like it was it was
abdusa turov who changed his approach
yeah one of the uh I guess one of the
main things is we still saw a d take C4
move but he was happy enough to leave
his Bishop on F4 and this is kind of a
known structure where black
takes the dark Square bishop and doubles
the pawns but in doing that you know you
waste a couple moves white is way ahead
in development and the bishop on G2 will
Well Place pieces in the center black
actually struggles to development in
these positions because there's all
kinds of threats and again don't be
fooled by the double pawns we've already
seen abdusa turn off successfully played
those before they're easy to defend and
in some cases if you get an end game
white is actually just ready to Dart
into the middle so
so I'm liking abusive trough here go
ahead agree uh I think Queen perhaps C8
I don't know if Queen C8 was the move
but it looked like a really comfortable
move exact same idea as Queen D7 so
I mean I I understand like trying to get
to to B7 but Queen C8 had the added
pressure of hitting White's Queen so
what you know why would you not want to
at least Force white to to make a
decision there and I I saw I saw why
Queen December somebody you're right can
we see it was better but it wasn't
punished after Rook to C1 White had to
move F5 I'm on and the difference is
that in that position I think if you
play E5 I actually I don't have the
computer probably so I thought there was
some discover Discovery but actually
Queen B7 would have worked anyway so I
actually don't know why can we do seven
was a blunder all right A6 is played I
think it's more like a blunder not a
blunder but a mistake as in other moves
were better like Queen C8 I think was
just a better move but I don't think
there's nothing like Queen D7 loses on
the spot
it's funny now white does get the F5
idea
um after A6 and has a big Advantage here
we have not seen Fabby
like you know in as tough of a spot as
he is right now in the opening so hey
whatever whatever chess.com is putting
in a snack area during these breaks with
these players I don't know everyone's
digging in because look at the change in
nordeback's demeanor his openings the
last two games I mean Bobby's dead here
he's dead we're shipping everybody
beastables you know
um beastables at the Break
um getting all jacked up is there is
there Knight D5
997 check and queen takes F7 dude that
is exactly what there was we have to
bring up the analysis board to show it
because we named it the a monometer for
a reason
look at white look at white completely
winning here but the win to really take
home to Mom and Dad was Knight D5 Bishop
C1 and then Amon Hamilton finds 97 and
queen F7 man sick nasty
is nasty that's doing your puzzle Rush
right there
that was that was Dirty by the way I
think even Knight D5 earlier was an idea
but okay we're already in a position
still great for Notre back but he did
just miss Knight D5
yeah but that's something that you know
hey I might see it if I was like you
know the Red Bull was uh peaking uh for
me during a match Danny but guess what I
was really assisted by the fact that I
know there was something I don't know
what it was right but just being told
that there's a tactic that wakes up
everybody
what exactly is pikamon Hamilton let's
be let's talk about that is pikamon
around 2 A.M in general
is Pokemon
yeah no Red Bulls deep that you want to
admit around 2 A.M
I would say uh the the main thing you
have to remember Danny is that's all
true but you know just subtract about 10
years from my life okay I think a long
time ago
by the way Fabiano caruana gets credit
for for flipping the script on the
storyline of that a monometer we are
back to an equal position and it's
because Notre Beck missed the
opportunities we talked about Amon
Fabiano has gotten the Queens off the
board and now who's better
yeah I think at this point if you're
purely looking at the board I like
Black's position I think the bishop is
strong the knights have let's say a lot
of squares taken away from them because
of Black's light Square pawns Pawn on B5
hitting A4 C4 F5 is covered there's just
there's squares that are covered
everywhere once that Knight gets out
from B8 you know if and when Knight C6
coming I I think I will definitely like
the position for a lot we're on move 30
and black has not completed development
according Knight D5 was brilliant
because if you took there was a check
but oh it just fluttered dude forgot the
Knight was guarding the Rook
forgot the Knight who the Knight didn't
move the entire game and it's the main
reason that black won the game
and Notre Beck pulls the old like you
missed the tennis ball and you look at
the racket to see if there's a hole in
it as if you didn't just miss it you see
Notre pack he leans back and he and he
points at the knight in the corner like
what the bro like what what just
happened there like like is there a hole
in the racket are you kidding me
absolutely yeah you know adjust the
strings there and Abby quite literally I
don't know what the evaluation of that
95 Queen F7 line was but I'm assuming it
was something to the effect of like plus
20 or Force mate and yeah it went from
that evaluation all the way back to a
win for Fabby that's it's just insane to
have that kind of turnaround and that we
talk about momentum shifts that's a huge
one because a tide match just became 6-4
with norterbeck you know probably in his
feelings a little bit about that I know
I'd still be thinking about that yeah
that's that's one where he may not have
the eval bar in front of him everybody
like we do he may not have the
amanometer or the knowledge of Knight D5
but he knows he missed something he
knows he was winning there and now that
eats at you even more right even more
than having the answer because now
you're like I know I let that get away
that's a heartbreaking one so uh
momentum is purely back in Fabian
carvana's Court
absolutely and this is kind of a
bit of an ideal position to play I feel
like if you're if you're Fabby and I say
that because it's a little bit of
gamesmanship I feel like in Blitz where
if you're able to play a seemingly
unambitious equal you know monotonous
position and in against someone it's
probably going to be a long grindy game
and man if that doesn't dampen your
spirits right well I don't even say a
bit of gamesmanship because he played
the alakins we were so focused on the
last blunder let me remind the fans that
Fabian oh wait no don't rebecc played it
exactly oh
that's an interesting choice that's
actually worries me because if he's
already choosing that type of spicy
opening
if you lose this game I'm on where you
chose an alkyne and white kind of grinds
you as you said Fabi has this solid
position you're down three games and now
you're regretting more than just the
blunders you made you're regretting your
match strategy because you chose an
alkyne as as a way to play in the three
minute portion that's a very risky
choice
exactly so we'll see if it pays off for
him
um I will give nordbeck a lot of credits
like no matter what has happened this
match I feel like he's been able to just
play the match like nothing seems to
have been affecting him but I don't
think he's thrown a game as big as he
just did
by the way I think that Miss was because
Queen B3 might have stolen a pawn just
spotting it but it's too late now either
way White's Advantage is still large
um and looming in typical Fabiano
fashion right he misses something but he
still maintains an incredibly big
advantage
yeah he's got a very very good position
here lots of space don't put a knight on
E7 because you lose your Bishop just
real quick tactics for the kids good
old-fashioned family fun right there
that's a good one I didn't notice that
especially because 97 is like where it's
one almost every piece to go it's what
you want to do right neither Knight is
happy where it stands you want to move
this Knight to E7 so you can play C6
because this is coming you want to move
this Knight to E7 to develop and maybe
come to G6 so it actually is irrelevant
irrelevant um and there he goes he stops
it
okay H6 is like
H6 is the kind of move where you have so
many things you want to do and there's
one annoying threat that's preventing
everything that at some point you stop
calculating and you're like okay let me
just prevent this one thing first yeah
he plays H6 and then rookie eight now
it's up to car wanna to to do something
with this space right you got it it
looks pretty but what are you gonna do
with it right what are you gonna do with
are you playing B5
like if you take the bishop and black
takes back with the Rook I think you're
more or less happy but black yeah love
to take with a pawn and then somehow
establish a knight on D5 similarly white
would wanna maybe take and then perhaps
play the move D5 and so it's like who
can achieve that first
95 is interesting you're opening up F3
F4
move but you know what it is I'm on if
the D file opens up we have tactics ah
but Notre brick spots it gets the queen
out of Dodge there were threats
everybody on the undefended queen
because of lack of development
yeah and that lack of development by the
way is not really going anywhere so yeah
uh yeah you still have the same same
problems later but H3 is you know it
it's not the easiest thing to defend
while still doing things in the center
you have to spend time going like King
Age Two or Knight E4 and King G2
wow interesting plays King H2 walks in
the face of Into the Danger D5 is gonna
fall and by the way when it does you
have a forking problem on C7
that's actually a really really nice
move F3 so patient happy to like be down
upon momentarily allow Queen H4
seemingly go on the defensive with uh
King H2 and I tell you that Swig of
water right there that was a that was a
confident swing no don't you love that
The Confident Swig as they call it
so hard to play against this and we
might be seeing exactly what we uh were
hoping that we weren't correct about but
foreshadowing that this alet time is
just not going to go well and you end up
down three games there'll be one more
game uh probably Danny before you know
the Midway point and it's gonna be so
important
I couldn't agree more as I as I
highlighted there's a night Fork on C7
so the queen has to tuck her tail
between her legs run back but it's all
white here I mean Bobby can play Bishop
F4 he could probably play F4 yep uh this
just this Knight has still not developed
wow G5 that's a spicy one G5 was not in
my candidate list but oh but literally
yeah the main plan of it was Knight F6
and he walked into it
the amount of meter goes crazy Notre
brick puts his head in his hand and I I
don't care I don't care if if G5 was the
best move for Fabi or not forget about
it the the truth is that was a very
risky decision by Notre back and I'm
gonna call it early I'm not saying that
he's not going to come back in this
match and I'm not calling the match I'm
saying I'm going to call Amman that in
my opinion that was lack of a match
experience it's too early to go for
those types of risky openings you and I
have commentated on a lot of SEC matches
and the one thing players like this do
when you're down three games in bullet
I'm on that's different now you gotta go
for spicy openings that get you
double-edged positions in my humble
opinion Knight F6 by notorbeck and the
alkyne was a blunder in regards to SCC
match strategy and I think it's going to
come back to haunt him
I I always like the the Bold cakes uh
Danny because you know they people need
to stand by uh what they believe more
often and hey that's a fair call
um norterbeck does need to to stick to
his game plan so to speak and we're not
in any type of like you know uh call in
the recruits no we don't need to back up
just yet I mean you were only down two
uh games there but it was the nature in
which he lost that previous game that
probably played into his decision to
play Knight F6
is what it's what Oman just said
everyone the reason I'm saying that and
notorbeck fans will be mad at me is
because it's okay he's young and he
hasn't played a lot of secs but the
reality is it was only two games and as
a mom said it was the nature of that
game but he was basically just worse and
losing start to finish why because the
Alex isn't played at a top level for a
reason because these guys know what to
do with it and Fabiano basically spanked
alakyne can I say that is that an
appropriate thing to say
um but I don't know if that's an
appropriate thing to say anymore you
know well it was it was not I can agree
on one thing that it was inappropriate
thing to say
okay
it was inappropriate or inappropriate I
said what I said okay you said what you
said all right either way we have a
three-game lead for the American Fabiano
caruana notabec abdusa turov back to the
first move opposite code Bishops yet
again but this one's better for abusive
turov than the Catalan we keep getting
yeah the one thing about this position
is
this is back to Great decision from
nordbeck
um fabby's up in the match so he will be
okay taking these lights slightly worse
positions you know what I mean uh you
know maybe he makes a draw but I think
this is great stuff to play in a blitz
match like this in the three-minute
portion white seems to have the push
here better Pawn structure opposite
Bishops Queens on the board which is
crucial that that gives white that
little bit of pressure so I I don't mind
this at all for an order back
this is the kind of position you can
still play right now forget about the
match score Notre picks stick to the
strategy avoid those those dubious and
and double-edged openings this is a
position that right now is kind of a a
two result one for white mm-hmm
yeah Bishop takes H4 was threatened so
that's why you played King H2 a great
move there and are you gonna see E5 and
he does F5 or E5 and takes I'm trying to
understand probably
computer doesn't like giving up the
space just yet I love that move for
tactical reasons on F7 it also makes D4
kinda tender although you have to watch
out for E2 so okay what's going on here
you can't yeah taking on E5 it was just
impossible I think
um because of Pawn takes back so that
was a cool move there but Bishop d8 is
gonna get the exclamation mark and for
good reason how do you stop yourself
from taking on E5 there that's and Fabi
didn't even spend that much time on it
yeah uh it was a very strong move look
at this move Bishop A5 that is full
board awareness homes I don't think I
would spot that but like he displays it
instantly kicks The Rook back plays D5
and this has turned around the bishop is
now eating Granite stuck to the pawn
wall you can't take D4 because E2 hangs
Fabiano is uh is working it today
and With No Diggity he likes to back it
up
are you should we give you more times
would you like to continue that
if you give me time I I I'm gonna just
go into No Diggity right now like what
what just what a great Jam okay sorry go
ahead
well The Rook on E2 is hit there's
actually not a way to defend it
strangely enough so white is never going
to threaten the Deep on and the other
issue is White's Bishop on B3 will not
be playing the game of chess without the
move C3 so that's why crazy enough white
just played Rook C1 because there's no
way to get the bishop back into the game
without Fonda C3
what's funny is I love that you
highlighted the pawn couldn't be taken
because the rook and The Rook couldn't
move because the bishop where it was I
kind of I kind of think Fabiano shooter
just stuck to that instead he retreated
the bishop and it's breathing a little
bit of life back into notorbeck's
position
that's right
so interestingly I mean C3 might have to
be taken because I'm wondering if yeah
and he needs to play F6 if he plays C3
he's actually freeing his Bishop there
so this is much more what what Fabi
wants but yeah unf6 is a little
the King on F6 a little tender but I
love this move Rook E3 the question is
do you play D4 or do you allow D4 this
is a big one I think you play oh he does
it but this is this is so risky man
you're cool your king is on F6
any four clean F5 and just I would just
play Queen E4 instantly because there's
no rookie eight okay I I didn't realize
I didn't realize how easy this was
you're right okay the players are
playing sun takes D4 and exactly this
will happen white gets some good pawns
as well but the Pawn's blockaded I think
this is great for nordeback opposite
Bishops with Rooks on the board
imbalance Pawn structure time getting
low yeah I think this is your best shot
okay
that's why you're a grand master and I'm
not you know I the that's the only
reason that's the only reason right
there your call in that position
you know all right
it's all different for you could have
been all but I made the wrong call and
that opposite code Bishop transition all
right um Rook takes E3
I I do agree with you jokes aside this
is the best chance Notre Beck has had to
win
uh well I guess he won the first game at
the three minutes uh Bishop A5 oh I
guess I thought there was a repetition
Bishop A5 Bishop B6 because the Rook had
to cover Rook D3 but yeah Bobby actually
played for more here
fascinating
dude if he plays C5 and The Rook is
getting trapped
you have to go Bishop oh can't go Bishop
B4 it's made it's mate
oh no dude he's cc5 and Notre Beck is
gonna blow it
oh my God yeah that's an E5 is happening
oh my gosh what a find the a monometer
Reveals All the moment C5 was played
Black's Advantage dips below the 50 line
a monometer strikes again oh this is
brutal A3 A2 and I think the king Bishop
Rook can all cover that epon King f8
Bishop F6 rookie two
dude losing this game would put Notre
back in a Four game hole and uh so tough
he's up against the wall of what you and
I know is SCC history right people have
overcome four game deficits everyone so
don't leave but five games has never
been overcome so you are officially up
against the the historical wall if you
will and Fabiano takes a confident sip
of water
gets up make sure he's feeling fresh oh
you wanted to make sure you check the
chat there at the end you know
and check and chat making sure the fans
are still with him yeah I'm on Hamilton
what do you do if you're Notre back
right now down four games
well
first of all I'm not sure the alkyne
should get another uh another spot on
stage so to speak uh there are certain
openings that have and haven't been
working and I would really I really
stick to what's been working it sounds
so basic but
um even if what's been working is maybe
not your preferred way to play your
favorite opening I think you have to
just accept that you know against a
certain guy on a certain day some
openings are just going to work better
or worse for you and now that he's got a
deficit in the match Danny guess what it
does have to think about being more
risky with his opening choices so the
alkyne is just not going to cut it
anymore it's not enough
yeah well it got away from him when he
played it but you said even though he
needs to fix his openings
Fabiano's not blundering I think we've
counted like one all day so if Fabiano
doesn't let it go it may not matter what
notorbeck abducer turn up does but it
does matter what you do don't go
anywhere the SCC will be right back
foreign
chess.com's game review recently got a
major update here are four Keynotes at
the end of each game review you will now
see a summary of the game from your
coach your performance rating for that
game and a quick grade for you and your
opponent in the opening middle game and
end game we've added a new
classification called Miss for when a
move fails to take advantage of an
opportunity but it is otherwise a sound
move we've also changed the definition
of blunder now a move will only be
considered a blunder if it loses
material or allows a Checkmate coach
will now draw arrows and highlight
squares when you hover over or click on
the highlighted words in the move
explanations this should make move
explanations easier to follow finally
coach's explanations will now reference
specific pieces and threads in
explanations making move explanations
much more intuitive the new game review
experience is available on chess.com
right now
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the Champions chess tour to
the candidates speed chess championship
title Tuesday feed a world championship
and so much more chess.com events has
all of the top chess tournaments played
both over the board and online
analyze and review games from the
world's greatest players with live
commentary cloud analysis opening
Explorer and table bases find all the
key event information including
schedules prizes results news reports
player bios tie breaks and more
and compete by voting for your predicted
results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
foreign
[Music]
Championship is presented by coinbase it
is back as we head into the second half
of the uh the three minute portion here
he's Amon Hamilton I'm Danny wrench and
we have a four-game lead for Fabian
carwana a month
you do and and so deserve uh Danny like
there are a lot of ways to get a
four-point lead but I feel like Bobby
has been the better player thus far he's
laundered so infrequently and he
definitely deserves this lead it's I
don't know whether he can maintain it
will he maintain it we know that at
times he's needed a lead for those who
didn't follow last year he had a
thrilling tiebreaker Victory though over
Arjun irigaisi uh as we look at fabi's
history here he's had some up and down
results he's had he's had some wins but
he's also had lopsided losses when he's
lost to be fair uh sometimes in the
first round often has made it to the
quarterfinal what do you read into this
year that maybe when Bobby isn't going
right it can go wrong quickly
but I'm reading into this here uh
fannies that Bobby's guaranteed to win
this match today because the only way he
loses is a very close win for nordeback
and we know that he won't lose that way
so exciting to know the results ahead of
time
yeah
well there he is
um we know that he he lost some matches
in a lopsided fashion right now he leads
by Four Points we head into three minute
and uh
right now he's probably sitting here
thinking about his opening prep making
sure he keeps keeps this ship you know
on on the uh the charted territories he
planned on I will say overall we already
see notorbeck being the one who's
bouncing around because really Fabiano
has kind of won the preparation battle
would you say that's fair
yes I I do think that fabi's openings
um have countered those from nordeback
really really well
um and I think that going into this uh
final three-minute portion I mean things
are going to go a little wild and wacky
as they always do in bullet but this is
the last chance and to be fair to
nordeback he's used every break really
really well uh perhaps better than Fabi
if I can award him that point so I'm I'm
looking for for this last 30 minutes of
the three plus one uh from nordeback to
be a big moment for him to claw back in
this match
agreed how will he have used this break
we're going to find out right now we
have our first traditional E4 E5 game of
the day if I'm doing my math right
yeah I think we had the um like the last
actually very last game before the break
was um e45 is the
um Italian Bishop C4 they have the
opposite Bishop position oh yeah yeah
okay yeah yeah yeah but I believe uh we
just saw rui so this is I think the
first one um of that sort
first rui we had the Italian I guess I'm
thinking that the truth is the storyline
overall has been a lot of catalans and
and since baseball and games so if we
are now transitioning into E4 as the
time controls get faster
um that's I wonder who you think that
bodes better for uh Fabi is
Bobby is a a very well prepared player
in the depths of the Spanish
um I think among the best right so I
think uh I think he'd be okay with that
right now we see Notre back on the clock
yeah I think players naturally default
to the things they know best as the time
controls get shorter so it's not a
surprise to me to see Fabby
experimenting with a few londons and
then eventually transitioning to E4
which I mean he's literally a world
leader
um at this opening
yeah
well here we go
um we're in a we're in a Spanish
Bobby up on the clock I think amman's
comments there will prove to be a
monster domus prophetic and that as the
time controls get faster we will see the
players just reverting to the openings
that they they play more often than
others maybe not pulling into the prep
they prepared specifically for an
opponent
um
and uh this looks pretty good for white
again fobby playing quickly because he's
comfortable with this position
yeah I feel like you really have to know
the ideas here because black just played
Queen C8 Rook d8 Queen B7 it's like I
don't think that you're looking at this
position and finding that over the board
that's that's a mark of someone who's
studied uh this right structure this
position knows where the pieces go and
that's just that's called understanding
so being on B7 for black pawn to B3
these are all very committal decisions
but he's happy to make them I wonder if
we're gonna see Knight D7 Knight C5 it7
also watches over the e-pawn which is
attacked right now
it is attack and there is a question of
where to put this bishop it's actually
funny because you just put it on B1 but
it really splits the communication
between the king side and queen side and
so instead you go to D3 but it's
interesting the the
the bishop comes to D3 and we're
immediately seeing it become a Target to
the idea that you highlighted her
that's right I almost think the bishop
E3 is not far-fetched here to take the
Knight on C5 remember the e-pawn would
still be hanging there and I also don't
think that the two Bishops is a serious
Edge uh for for white or black to have
here so happy to play Bishop takes
Knight on C5
Fabiano quickly meets H6 with Rook D1
he's maintaining his time Advantage you
know one thing we haven't shouted out a
lot of as far as the overall story lines
the two players are holding to here is
Fabiano has also been up on the clock
more often than not I would say
throughout the match
oh no question no question at all and
norderbeck is quite the player with low
time but you know I always uh make this
reminder PSA to people it's like you
think of someone who's really good low
on time like re-shook and it's like
pre-shook might be the best player in
the world when he has no time but what
he is not is he is not better than
rishook with lots of time yeah exactly
and I would say that's often the sign
people who are great at time scrambles
have often mismanaged their clock very
consistently because now they have no
choice but to build that muscle right if
you can't constantly get yourself stuck
under a heavy bar I guess you learn how
to lift it and the point is like uh
that's not a thing you want to do to
always be the first player under a
minute and Notre break is about to be
just that
yep that's really well said
um Bishop C4 looks like the move here I
I guess there's one interesting thing
which is that the a pawn always needs
attention so I wonder if like Rook takes
D1 how do you take it back
I like Bishop C4 I also like ideas where
I go aggressive here I don't know which
Knight square is okay he goes for Knight
D5 and the reason is that this trade
also opens up pressure on the e-pawn
um
and if you if you take regarding
regarding the move order if you take
here and take here I actually think I
can take here first right maybe a little
Tempo on the queen
absolutely
so once again Notre back on the clock
okay
so at this point it's almost like Pawn
for Pawn might be coming up Queen C4 no
yes C4 okay yeah I kind of forgot that
that was uh that was playable I don't
know why I had the pawn on C3 just never
forget about explosive situations that's
uh the fault is mine
sorry I had to do it never forget about
it never mind um don't cut the wrong
wire
can you hear the bomb exploding in your
head like I can
you're in today's such a good day for
that joke
okay you're such a comedian I'm just a
comedian
um but it actually is making a sound
effect if you can't hear it I can and I
really find it entertaining so I'm not I
don't know I'm not on your board
actually I can't hear it
got it okay anyway well back to the
position white has reinforced the strong
Knight now advances the queen side and
okay the D file is dominated and the B3
Pawn is hanging but C5 would fall with
it yeah this is this is turning into a
position where tactics might just like
like Knight F6 right is is destructive
in Every Which Way But Queen takes C5 if
it's unplayable yeah King f8 how do you
not get out of that but now just Queen
C3 back and apple Pawn
yeah maybe he should have gone for the
most craziest of tactics there but with
no time it's understandable and as you
highlighted this is the reason you need
time yeah exactly exactly
now you don't have a lot on the clock
with very little time left apparently
white missed a wind there but either way
Fabi is keeping the pressure
that's the thing is you
I mean at this point whites Knight on F3
wants to get involved but as soon as you
move Knight D4 happens
this is not comfortable at all like I
know it's gonna say like misses here and
there but I think white is uh is doing
really well
yeah
by the way the clock is fascinating here
both sides under 10 seconds
the tactics actually in the end black
wins the pawn but apparently it's not
good because I have no idea what's going
on neither do the players that was that
was actually a crazy tactic
um I didn't see it it's it's just like
moving so fast this is what time
scrambles are all about we might see
nordeback demonstrate look he's getting
low on time all the time Danny but
there's a reason that he feels
comfortable doing it it's because hey
he's a wicked speed test player so let's
see if he can pull this up
oh but here comes the a pawn and the C
Pawn is very strong does he settle on a
draw no no he wants more but with it go
for more
but with it he's risking it that c Pawn
is out of control there's no Rook takes
before what takes you seven
maybe that wasn't the best it actually
gave up the perpetual
yeah man I think maybe some sort of you
know Queen check to get your queen
covering a checking Square for black and
then play C7 was correct
okay oh wow
perhaps Poetic Justice with the peaceful
result there because I'm not sure which
player deserved that more it felt like
Notre Beck you know really struggled all
game as black on the black side of that
Spanish got himself in a chance to win
so you kind of felt like okay he earned
it that's right in the end there's no
denying that white was the one who
really had the best chances and Bobby
let it slip
that's right but we also got to see a
little bit of a glimpse into the
resourceful side of nordeback like we
could talk and and by the way I think
we're using as we should the the bias of
what's actually happening in front of us
when you see someone low on time and
let's say you see them consistently uh
making mistakes in time pressure and the
matches you know a four-game deficit
because of it and you're like okay he
probably should watch that you know he
shouldn't be doing that but if nordeback
was up four games in the match we would
be probably saying something different
so it's nice to see games like that
because it reminds you like no every
time he's down to seconds he's not just
dead lost he's not he is pretty damn
resourceful Danny and we got to see uh
the talent on this play there
yep
yep yep
um
yeah chat wondering if this is a bit of
a preview to what we're going to see
with bullet we'll see
I hope that bullet makes this map like
the thing is this three minute uh for
being realistic I think needs to end
with an order back
somewhere within like two maximum three
points of of Fabi if I'm being honest uh
if it's at like a four game deficit I
mean you're in the territory of needing
to Beat Bobby and Bullet at like an
overwhelming score like you know six to
two type of thing
yep yeah I mean we don't know what these
guys have in store for us in bullet
they've never played in bullet they've
actually never played in this format
either
um and here we go we got a little bit of
uh of a shout out right a uh time
machine back to last year's first round
event where the 1-1 segment was an
absolute Thriller between Fabiano
caruana and arjunior or geissy so
um from that perspective Fabi at least
you know his nerves have been there if
it does get close but I'm with you
noderbeck Notre back has to make it
closer than four games I think right
yep agreed yep
all right well once again we're in a
position they they kind of played before
not the exact one but the openings are
are consistent today
Karma once again up about 20 to 30
seconds on the clock as has been all day
Yep this looks pretty
um this looks pretty nice for white but
I'll say like it looks super equal and
that's not just because of the eval
although that's uh always nice to back
up your claims with uh with the engine
on your side but it's more of that it's
so symmetrical that's that's the thing
there's just it's tough to find any
differences here there's no two Bishops
there's no imbalance pawns nothing
there's no weaknesses for either side
the only advantage that white really has
is like a little bit more space and sort
of piece activity but I don't think that
it's enough on its own
yeah
and I'm looking at the mass strategy and
thinking that
I criticized Notre back for playing the
the alkynes too early and I I think it
was fair but if you keep just taking a
bunch of time off the clock in positions
like this that may not work either
um because at this point you're down and
you've got to change things
I do feel like in the the I'll call them
the small positions like the opposite
Bishop ones the ones where there's just
a minute New Edge for one side I feel
like Bobby has been doing more of the
out playing in those spots nordeback has
actually had his flashy chances uh
taking advantage of tactics
um on on Fabi launching like get some
interesting attacks tactics he had one
or two games where Fabi missed something
and there's only real chances this match
have been in those spots so it's
actually these grindy positions where I
think Abby's totally comfortable and has
displayed that in a number of different
cases he's actually able to outplay even
sometimes down a pawn
yeah it's funny the different styles of
of different players and
some of these grinded out positions if
you're Magnus Carlson you like these
positions against Fabiano because Fabian
and Magnus are both very very good and
Magnus just tends to be a little better
but if you're noted back you really
don't want these positions against
faziano because he's uh he's so solid
he's not gonna break
that's right he hasn't thus far
um you know these top guys they're only
gonna give you so many chances uh Danny
during a match like this to actually
take advantage of which is why you know
as the you know I guess as the person
behind in the match right now you have
to take literally every opportunity that
that you get
yeah
all right Knight A4 interesting it
invites doubled pawns if there's a trade
here everyone but the idea is that the B
file becomes
a place to get targets although right A6
is hanging you can't take it right away
because there's a check Queens don't
move like that there you go there's a
check
and I guess the question is just like
are you really gonna beat Fabiano
Carolina from this position you know
it's like
just kind of sit there and reminisce
like is this really the the recipe right
here is this really the recipe for
Success
um and as we ask it in that slightly
sort of sarcastic tone the answer is
probably no
um Alex a lot of time is gonna be eaten
off the clock I mean you're dealing with
a position where
I could say that White's probably
slightly better but it's the slightest
of betters right
slightest of Bettors TM I'm on Hamilton
um
Queen to C4 Rook can come to B3 and you
can try to double but I guess the one
thing to uh notrex credit is
we keep talking about the the time
scramble Dynamic if they get into pure
time scrambles we like Notre back more
than we do Fabiano usually but you still
have to have something to it and here
we're just going to have a rook ending
where the extra Apon uh especially given
that you're gonna lose the E2 Pawn isn't
enough and if you defend it here comes
Rook B6 so it's
it's equal yeah it's slightly better for
white but
I just don't really can't possibly find
this to be enough
the slightest of betters
I locked up
a lot right
and yeah I mean good good luck winning
this all that's really happened in this
game unfortunately nordeback is time has
come off the match clock yep and you're
still playing the game by the way it's
not even over
yeah and if Bobby wants he can he can
probably milk another I mean two minutes
off of this clock that may sound weird
to people first looking at the 20
seconds and 15 seconds but with
increment
and that clock running non-stop
um you know you can get a lot of total
time off of the game clock and still
hold a draw so not good for Notre breaks
Mass chances yeah as you were speaking
uh unfortunately Abby just did something
really strange for his standards which
was he just allowed King E4 and he had
to stop King E5 invading so he had to
give up a pawn here which
should actually be quite bad for his
position
yeah
sorry I didn't see it but you're right
the a monometer points out where I lost
my focus white gets a huge Advantage
after winning that pawn
and he should convert this so okay Notre
back fans right unite this is a match
here if he gets this dub and it's only
three games he is keeping this thing
close as the time controls get faster
yeah Fabi has very clear operation here
Rook C6 maybe Rook d8 oh that doesn't
actually do much here
this is one where the eval bar is unfair
the other way we say the eval bar when
it's 50 50 makes it seem like it should
be equal this is one that it was giving
white a huge Advantage but I don't think
it was
wait
wow almost on time
wow
that is a
rookie mistake from a veteran player to
uh to put it like wow and it was right
when it was so drawn Nordica was
actually just shaking his head last turn
that he allowed it to be complete drawn
like oh I couldn't finish my sense I was
gonna say like the eval bar made it seem
like it was easy but Fabi shows that
there's plenty of drawing chances but
unfortunately loses on time before I
could complete the thought
wow well Notre back yeah go ahead no
Danny it's it's back to what we were
talking about you got to take every
chance look is nordeback gonna look back
on this moment and be like oh yeah you
didn't deserve that full point uh no
probably not he's gonna be looking full
steam ahead take that in stride this is
you know online chess Danny it happens
also for those Fabiano caruana fans who
don't want to hear it is that a preview
of the bullet because the problems we've
seen for Fabi in those Mutual just
all-out time scrambles right it's like
the gloves are off and you are just
flagging your opponent is where I would
have to say Notre back is the favorite
he plays he's played more online chess
he grew up online we've seen the pesky
resourceful style so I'm not saying Fabi
isn't isn't you know he's the top player
in the world but I would probably take
Notre back in most of those Wild West
Affairs I think you'd agree with that
and so that's a bad sign for Fabi for
him to lose a position that's a draw on
on time
that's right and uh now it's almost like
uh you know smelling blood for nordeback
that's going to give him a little bit of
energy he knows that he didn't fully
deserve that that point but guess what
there's probably been points previously
in the match where you know results were
claimed that you didn't necessarily
expect and certainly the engine wouldn't
but that's just how it goes down in real
time
I love how Chad is finding a way to
blame me for jinxing Fabi I haven't even
jinxed father all day go blame yourself
chat geez Louise all right here we go
you think is not a thing what do they
love to just hate on you Danny because I
I was the one who said
Fabi will not lose this match because he
only loses blowout matches but you know
you you are getting the Flack here so
this is honestly one of the reasons I
love commentating with you everyone
loves commentating with the partner who
gets all the hate and I I I don't I
don't uh resent that at all but all
right jinxing isn't even a thing chat
grow up we're not five you don't have to
leave the remote in the same position
because when you put it there your team
got a home run okay we're all adults
here actually some of you are probably
you know children violating twitch terms
of service which is a you problem so
therefore any inappropriate jokes I make
are your parents issues not mine okay
back to the position Fabiano rebounding
has an advantage G5 is weak
your thoughts G5 weak but more
importantly I think it's zero counter
play that's that's what hurts me more
Knight G6 yes you want to play night H4
Knight F4 but that pawn is going to
disappear the king is actually going to
be
I believe surprisingly safe on G3
yeah and anytime you play A5 there's
going to be B5 to meet that so super
tough to generate any kind of play here
yeah I love Queen E3 because it
highlights your point that black is
going nowhere you can't ever play Knight
G6 because then I'll take G5
that's right I was highlighting Rook H1
because the moment black gave that file
I I just you know if you like it then
you put a rook on it as Beyonce once
said so I think Rook H1 will come
and as you pointed out black has no
counter play
yeah I'm I'm actually
I'm really struggling to identify it
it's almost like the queen on V6 is
terrible you need to bring it back to d8
or watches the g-pawn uh and maybe you
know comes with some other threats
um Knight takes G5 I'm wondering if
there's Knight takes E5
some sort of weird like
it probably doesn't work I think I think
you should just take with the queen yeah
he does I was gonna say just take with
the queen and point out that there's no
discovered attack and he does just that
I I think that that works by the way the
queen will also come to F6 next and F7
is is a problem
that's super uncomfortable like you
almost need to play Queen d8 but then
you're you're so admitting you know that
you're that you're just down upon
well at this point there's seven minutes
left so more than likely we get it we
get one more three-minute game and that
is it meaning I don't think this game's
going for seven minutes and I don't
think we're gonna get two more games so
um for Fabiano if he wins and pushes the
lead back to four that's big time
that's right
that's right it's like Black's very
solid here it's tough for white to do
much more than what he did which is win
that bomb but
I really don't have uh too many
recommendations as for what to do
yeah
okay but you you did point out that
white is white is uh lacking plans I
guess now that you're winning right
you're like where's the next idea to
convert
and uh now the D4 Pawn how do you defend
that actually and the G5 Knight because
if you moved the Knight to F3 G4 was
gonna fall and here we go norterbeck is
winning the pawn back
yeah there's a I think it just needed a
slower treatment like after Knight G5
Rook G7 aim G3 like maybe F4 first king
G3 Knight back to F3 it's like a really
slow thing but you know there's things
to be careful of with your King on G3
Knight on F5 Queen on C7 there's a lot
of trickery but I think that was still
the right approach don't play King G3
now chat is that that's uh that's a
problem I already highlighted before
I'll do it again that's a night Fork
oh that's the second night for it um he
just takes D4 and takes D5 with check
regain this one advantage this is a big
deal though for nordeback to have this
position
yeah this is great for black
yeah this is
this is I I don't think that Fabiano's
gonna lose this but I'm pointing out
that's not Unthinkable here because the
queen and Knight are a dangerous Duo
kind of like me and you buddy takes
takes B6 and black is
problem-less okay he gets the Queens off
the board and you leave me hanging on my
dangerous Duo joke but it's okay I won't
hold it against you
um
but this is going to be a draw I guess
the one thing for Fabiano he gets more
time off the clock but that's not a good
result Fabiano wanted to win this one
oh absolutely one upon clean for nothing
and ordered by Claude his way back so I
don't know this is uh it should really
just be a draw
you should there's Bishop eighth coming
to watch out for at some point keep your
eyes on it Pawn on G5 is uh quite
annoying yeah he goes for it and I'm
like wait a second am I am I running I'm
running but I'm not fast enough a lot of
pawns are going to disappear from the
board as well
yeah
okay
C3 and I think we'll get did he want
this is he he's gonna play for E4 and E5
I guess so
try to push the king back once he came I
I think E4 could even potentially risk
something for white
yeah okay
all right but now now what's going on
table base gives you a heart attack I
don't care that it says draw Notre back
is pushing for a win and it would be his
second in a row
I'm sure I like this or
I mean I think this is like a forced win
for black dude the table base just went
from draw to win in one move and I think
in Blitz it was already as you said it
was already a win for black in many ways
I mean this is such a tough position to
hold it's not even I this shouldn't even
be close
um I think this is going to be a super
easy win for nordeback I'm surprised to
see that table base thing
because yeah in practice this is just
not even I shouldn't even be close
wow well I mean we got to take it in
here everybody we got a comeback coming
out we got to come back here
this is gonna be his second game in a
row and none of the Fabi fans want to
hear it but both have been time scramble
bullet foreshadowing-esque is that a
thing Time Dash scramble Dash
foreshadowing bullet that's like a long
thing but they've been Time shadow
foreshadowing
you go a lot of Shadows a lot of Shadows
happening that's my point the game of
shadows
now there's uh there's one thing that's
interesting earlier on I think he missed
a chance to do it properly
um
I I think that he's winning it but he's
just doing it slowly but he is getting
it done
yeah okay it's still winning he's got 93
and it's over wow Fabiano runs his
fingers through the freshly frod out fro
but he's gonna need more than a great
looking head of hair to Stave off the
notorbeck comeback
and you know what he's got more than a
great edit here so that's that's
convenient
he sure does that means he's got two
more things than I have he's got chest
skills and a great head of hair
um those weren't the things that I was
thinking of
but all right we're back in the Catalan
we're white Parts weighs with the light
squared Bishop
that has gone well for Fabiano so far
today if you're just tuning in we had a
very instructive five minute portion
like I literally I recommend going
through those games Fabiano put on a
master class as black in these cattle
impositions
um but right now all momentum is
favoring notorbeck that's right you know
you can uh read in to the psychology a
little bit because yeah this has been a
very good opening for Fabi the whole
match but now all of a sudden doesn't it
feel just a little bit different because
it's a little pep in the step here for
nordeback Rook takes D5 is that a move
for the fans it is there's a back rank
it's calling my name
like hey oh we missed it Rook takes D5
and the queen had E8 look at that you
see Fabi saw that he missed it he sat up
and he was like you know who's your gut
he's very glad
and that's such a classic uh situation
that you know when you're just a little
rattled from the previous game I mean
Abby hasn't missed something like that
in a while uh this whole match so you're
back strum a few games together and all
it took was that just flagging right
that momentum shifter that was huge for
Nordic back and hey guess what he's got
a great position here I know it doesn't
look like much but opposite Bishops he
has the push
it is and it's an obstacle Bishop
attacking a king side but not not the uh
not the one for black that we saw all
day there's no light squares here
although Queen F7 does threaten this
this is the this is the potential of a
very dangerous attack for white if
somehow the dark Square Bishop can get
going with the Rooks
or I don't think he has
yeah H4 as well that's right
but H4 is played he's gonna play G4 and
H5 Dirty Dog
he's gonna go for G5 and put the Rook
here that's what he's gonna do well yeah
at this point is uh kind of being coaxed
into it it might be G takes H5 though
King F2 and yeah I think this is the G1
the treatment
yeah okay
it's a double-edged one
um but we like white again Notre
breakfast won two in a row if you're
just tuning in it was a four game lead
for Fabiano caruana but uh
Notre back is on the comeback Trail
I mean that's it that's an actual Trail
by the way come back Trail
is it been on it yeah
not much of a hiker
yep
great hikes brother all right Queen D2
Rook A6 there's a d-pawn hanging why
can't I okay H4 Falls
my
I'm on all right okay Queen F4 threatens
Rook takes D5
yes he allows us six now you almost have
to go Rook E1 unless there are
tactic set play
did you just say saktics like
sacrificial tactics did you just combine
sacrifice and tactic into a word sactic
I would love to take credit for this but
I have to be honest Danny you just came
up with that
that was great I I heard you say sack
dick no you you that's yours Danny and
if push comes to shove I'm willing to go
on record saying you came up with that
okay that's me not I'm on this time
sactic
TM
we did it
a sectic
there's some six tactics in the air if
you look at G7 we could sack dick the
bleep out of this I could sactic all
night
you know sorry yeah we're doing it now
like I said like I said you came up with
it
let's make sure okay in fact I'd like to
permanently distance myself
there you go if it distance yourself
even further from Danny's ability to
stick his foot in his mouth
um okay wait but D5 is hanging in a lot
of positions you have to be careful
because Rook takes E2 the king hides and
how do you deal with the pin and he goes
for it yeah so Rook E2 King F1 Bishop H3
but it's the king G1 hello get on the
dark squares with a light Square Bishop
for the opponent this is very very
tricky and the kid takes a sip of water
I've never been able to look as cool as
they do when they drink water
I just don't have the ability to look
confident
all right Rook to d8 F6 is hanging dark
squares are abundant for black sorry for
white on the attack
yeah there might be yeah because Rook
let's say Rook F7 there's so many ways
for white to penetrate the position
Queen B8 uh Rook G5
um
yeah just sactics everywhere there's
there's mate on h8 look at that Rook to
G5 courtesy of Amman Hamilton
that's actually that's actually a really
strong threat I mean there's rookie once
you have to be a little careful but
there's also Rook F7 Bishop takes F6
because the queen C7 also leads to me
yeah
by the way your move Rook G5 right here
right now it's pretty good you're gonna
beat me look at the amanometer I'm just
telling you the Amon Amina Rook G5
F and a cotton
last game of the year Dan you can't hold
anything back now we're headed to Bullet
with a one game lead that's incredible
that this has turned from four to like
Abby is like spiraling like you've you'd
never think was possible
and you can't even take the Rook again
because there's Queen C7 stuff or now
now you just use the dark squares
I assume
uh
I think the best way to do this is
always always like I'm always happy that
it's someone else's problem you know
yeah
like Queen B8 is that the right idea
okay this one hits F6 yeah that that's
probably good enough yeah rookie six
Queen G7 I think he's getting it done
yeah too many threats not enough time
for black queen G7 is made on the board
and we have liftoff boys and girls a
frustrated Fabiano caruana right there
but an elated Notre back abducer you're
off
a match of momentum and uh and
psychological swings Danny because there
was not really any reason that nordeback
should be back in this match when you
think about if that game had just been a
draw like it was supposed to be if he
didn't win on time were and it would
like you know totally different parallel
universe so take your chances and Nordic
did it's going to be an exciting bullet
portion Danny because it's now down to a
single thing yeah I guess the one thing
if you're probably on a car wanted you
get some you get some friendly advice
you get some coaching and you say like
hey man
keep your energy up you've been here
before in a really tight battle like
last year uh so you can do it again and
win in overtime even though clearly he
needs to do something to shake the
momentum you know what I often shake my
shaker bottle with ag1 because I take
that stuff because it actually makes me
feel good okay ag-1 is literally your
next smart move I'm not kidding they are
an awesome partner of ours I do drink it
I mainly drink it I'm gonna be honest
because it tastes good all right I'm
like a little kid inside and it's
actually I know you're looking at it
you're like green vegetables you're
wrong it's phenomenal I don't know I've
actually been on record on the SEC uh
coining that the chess.com flavor uh
it's just greenchest.com you know what
can I say you got you got something
cooking over there it is it is it's the
chest.com flavor use the command ag1 go
check it out seriously uh and if you go
to drink ag1.com chess use uh use our
code because uh because it's a fun
partnership and we're hoping you enjoy
it and um all right I hope everyone's
enjoying the SEC because it's been a
blast I'm on Hamilton and I are uh are
gonna take our last break before the
bullet portion commences I recommend you
get a snack maybe some ag1 some fresh
energy don't go anywhere the speeches
Championship presented by coinbase
returns with bullet
foreign
chess is great for the brain but it's
also fun to play and chess kid makes it
easy to have fun whether your child is a
total beginner or a prodigy they can hop
on and find a well-matched opponent from
around the world at any time chess kid
is the safe parent-approved way for your
child to play chess online
chess kid is educational
the kids it feels just like playing but
chess is a great way to learn patience
strategy and critical thinking chess kid
features a comprehensive training
program that guides kids to level up on
their way to Mastery there are more than
fifty thousand chest puzzles and a whole
library of entertaining videos that
teach strategies tactics openings and
end games specifically for kids
chess kit is easy whether you're a
parent helping your child a coach
managing dozens of kids or a school of
hundreds signing up is free and easy so
what are you waiting for
foreign
did you know you can add Emoji to your
online games and Analysis boards simply
click on the Emoji palette icon select
your emoji and left click on the board
you can choose from a host of notations
animations emoticons and even your
favorite chess personalities
emoticons it will fade away after a few
seconds
however notations and special animations
remain on the board until they are
cleared to clear them simply left click
on the Emoji or hit the clear all button
at the bottom of the palette
fun try them all on chess.com
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
it's bullet time baby we're back baby
he's I'm on Hamilton Danny wrench we
have a thriller right now with Fabiano
caruana and notrebrech abusator up I'm
on a one game a single one game
separates these two as we head into the
fastest time control
yeah we I I feel like what we've got in
front of us Annie is the match that we
expected to have but we didn't get here
the way that we expected to get here
because right there was a big lead at
Fabiano opened up a four-game lead in
fact it looked like he was kind of
cruising but now you see the face of
someone who's gonna scratch in the
forehead a little bit and saying wait a
minute uh he is right back in this match
he being Nordic abdusatora yeah it's
true especially because when he had that
four game lead there were a couple games
that he uh he could have won during that
comeback we just saw from Notre back
right so Fabiano not only has to forget
about the fact that he had a foreign
game lead but that he probably had
decent chances to protect it and he
didn't and right now he uh he's only up
one game and this kid is good in time
scrambles he is and we're gonna get to
see basically a condensed version of
what we've been seeing because let's
let's call it like it is Danny we've had
bullet Games built into every Blitz game
so far and it seems maybe obvious to say
but no not every Blitz game ends up in a
Time scramble but in this match I think
it has
a Greektown population us which is a
town that exists between America and
Canada you and I now live in agreement
town for the rest of the match here we
go with the rui Lopez
agreed
look at that look at that we're together
me and you all right here we go a Lopez
once again you called it Iman you said
as the time controls get faster players
tend to revert to their uh to their most
comfortable openings we know that
Fabiano loves himself some some Roy
Lopez and and here we go
yeah this is a very classic approach D4
D5 to blend the bishop on B7 you're
gonna see players you know as as happens
in bullet default to not only openings
they know but moves and plans that
they're familiar with and can execute
quickly
and you see how deep the theory goes
here because the opening bar came back
there we had eval bar and then we had a
transposition occur on move 18 where we
were back in known Theory so this stuff
has been played many times by many
players
um
and uh I I don't really trust the email
bar a lot in these spots too I think
that white tends to be a little favored
because of space in these things but
it's very close in anyone's game right
now yeah and the other thing is like
this is bullet which means you're really
looking for playability not necessarily
that engine Advantage like a lot of
times the engine really prefers the
position but guess what if Black's plans
are so so easy and you can get those
moves off really quickly that means a
lot
well you called it after that on passant
which is now for us after I updated the
system thank you coinbase the C3 Pawn is
now weak and uh and now so fobby wants
to get rid of it
but we get a protected
punt gosh that feels good for black it
really does the the one thing is I think
the position is still so interesting
because black wants to put this Knight
on D6 uh Bishop on H6 white on the other
hand blockades the b-pawn effectively
with an item B3 so I'm not sure which
side I like here
uh yeah I agree although
I tend to lean black I feel like this
Edge case Pawn is a little more powerful
than the centrally blockaded pass Pawn
but yeah but you're right I mean this is
like anything else so far in this Lopez
a bit of a coin flip
truly and the bishop on H6 uh seems like
it's not doing much but D2 Square means
if a knight ever occupies it black wants
to trade off that Bishop he can the
break in the position is F5 but you're
not really going to check that out there
until you're ready
mm-hmm
agreed agreed agreed agreed F5 is the
move we see white getting ready to meet
it black patiently awaiting now the
queen has snuck into A4 but she's like
ah just kidding I was just coming in to
say hi like your in-laws Uninvited to
dinner here they are why the are you
here get out sorry that I blacked out
we're back
yeah it started as a really nice
reference and then I realized you
weren't commentating anymore
yeah okay here we go I'm back I'm back
no more in-laws at dinner the queen has
left but G5 is coming G5 and we live
where's candy when you need him
truly G4 is such a big threat actually
I'm not sure how to deal with this
Knight H2 and F3 Rose but might be
necessary
no but it's looking good for Notre back
this is
this will be the fourth victory in a row
for Notre back if he gets it and that is
not what Fabiana wants
oh man Knight G3 Knight F5 is a really
easy plan though
but the more this game goes on okay he
steals the pawn and gets away with it
what I'm what is going on yeah this is
not trending in the right Brook H4 Maybe
a monometer down there shows black was
winning but we're back to equal oh no
and both teams are in danger such a big
threat
wait you just walked into it
same idea yeah yep
dude
Nordic just walked into that blunder
with Queen C8
yeah that was that was really walking
into it
literally the definition of it it's
somehow still a crazy game here who's
walking into what what is going on here
oh my gosh this Mac is mating white he's
lost
he's lost his marbles
what game was that Danny what look at
that look at the amount of meter look at
the up and down he was down a Rock
it's it's like it's like a life support
here you've got this this is not good we
want stability here this is nutty
huh oh my gosh
Abby has wait a minute can we actually
quantify this has he lost four games in
a row like it was he didn't was there a
draw in between there might have been a
draw in between maybe maybe but it's
it's downhill Fabio hasn't won a game in
a long time let's put it that way
Fabiano has not it's it is it's a
four-game win streak confirmed this is
this is where you you you you have to
stop the bleeding to use the chest
phrase right you have to you have to
take care of the momentum even if you
get a draw here as Fabiano you can't let
it completely run off the tracks
that's right
but it's not looking good again
yeah so these positions are always
interesting they feel good for black
because you have this you know
unassailed Knight that's gonna land on
E5 but what white Chen really does in
these positions is leaves the Rooks
hitting F7 and then slowly over the
course of maybe many moves trades the
Bishops and then trades the knights and
then the position with heavy pieces is
not that good right and the reason is
not is because black has a million and a
half Pawn Islands which we don't know a
pond island is any grouping of ponds
whether one or more that means there is
just too much to defend in the major PCN
game so wow Knight takes H2 from Fabiano
you can get away with that
apparently he did
more world holy smokes the tactics are
flying here
yeah this is this is crazy I my heart is
going out to Fabiano he's a friend but I
don't have time to think about that
because at this point
the momentum is so impressive for Notre
back even though Fabiano has also let
several of these games go he doesn't
want to do it again got it gotta not
lose this game I'm on totally the eight
is hanging don't forget that
um so say six
okay and what comes next Queen G7 here
there's Knight G3 Bishop G4
and this is also good because H5 is just
hanging that's right take it
you yeah take with the Knight right like
don't yeah don't trade the Queens
bro
bro it's about to be five in a row bruh
just bra chess bra about to be five in a
row what is going on this is
unbelievable
really really remarkable the the
landslide that fabi's on right now you
talk about needing to stop I mean at
this point the ball is just rolling down
the hill and I'm not sure it can be
stopped yeah
okay well they're back in this line but
again fobby goes for the bishop D6
instead of your suggestion to uh
oh no no no no no but Fabi goes Bishop
G3 instead of taking fling 95 which was
your suggestion right yeah sorry I
thought you meant that the interesting
thing was norderbeck oh yeah Pawn takes
D4 exactly five that was good yeah I
don't know why he's back to this I agree
yeah so if you're missing we're
referring to
um a couple of London games that were
played in the in the slower time
controls back when we were in five
minutes so
right now we are in a London
here we see this bishop B5 idea it's a
thematic one to get rid of that
dangerous light squared attacker
yeah Rook A5 is obviously not possible
so very technically that d-pawn is lost
there it is there there it goes uh these
are weird positions because despite
being up a pawn it you don't have full
confidence in White's position it's one
of those londons where you don't have a
Pawn on D4 which is extremely rare
Fabiano playing well he's up 20 seconds
on the clock up a clean Pawn but we've
seen him lose games already before in
the time scrambles right so
that's the problem
E3 maybe B3 Knight B5 kind of I mean
yeah you can trade Queens as well
actually
yeah wait Knight C6 it's a huge
Advantage might even be winning like
yeah C4 or something
passphones are coming there's gonna be
two of them here in short order so if
this is the game where carwana does
indeed stop the bleeding and right the
ship
um you know the Thriller maintains
itself we have 20 minutes to go Notre
back just res oh Rook takes D6 didn't
even see it nice little finish it was a
nice finish I think it was completely
Unstoppable like The Rook was in a
permanent pin so just I only have a kind
of a model game there from from Fabi but
norterbeck probably just played too
quick Danny I don't know why he switched
his London line back to that that was
much worse yep
yep all right a tide match we promised
you a thriller all right you were like
oh drama hype commentators whatever uh
you know that's what they suing that's
what you sound like when you're trolling
Us in chat so you know you think you
sound cool you're like
commentators that's what they sound like
I'm on in our head do they not
that's oh no I've met some twitch
Chatters Danny they sound exactly like
that so definitely living up to The
Stereotype so right now you said we were
hyping up fake drama the drama is real
we have a nail biter
um like I'm once said maybe not how we
thought we'd get here in a massive wild
swinging Affair uh but we're dead locked
with 20 minutes to go
and I have to say just in terms of
bullet playability White's position
looks easy looks fun lots of tactics
weird hanging stuff everywhere for black
to watch out for and Rook D1 rookie one
is so easy to do
also someone who seems to have saved
something in the tank as far as openings
going on for bullet right he played a
lot of D4 we had a lot of catalans now
he's switching exclusively to E4 we know
that the young man plays himself a
scotch enjoys himself a nice Scotch this
guy right here okay I also play Bad
Scotch openings against him on Hamilton
um but the point is
yeah exactly well never forget the queen
on H1 never forget
um anyway
the point is Notre back going back to
his his main repertoire and these sharp
E4 games where he's at home and right
now it's paying off with another really
good position
I was gonna say what about Bishop I was
going to say Bishop G3 but he did Bishop
D2 the idea of being protect the Jeep on
and this is why I maybe wanted Bishop G3
so that there was no Queen H4 in the
future no because I think if you keep
the pawn on G4 look at that Knight on E8
Danny F6 off limits D6 off limits F5 and
H5 were off limits until until that
by the way the move that fobby missed
was Queen H4 he played 98 just to point
out the reason that was a double
question mark for the fans wishing we
had time we don't have time to highlight
all mistakes right now I'm bullet but
even though the eval Bar says White's
better from a practical perspective this
is anyone's game this is like uh yeah
this is gross there's some Queen H4 that
looks way too tempting play
um but that's it this is the problem
this is a problem that's a really really
good reply
yeah
I mean G6 there's a world where you can
I was gonna say could you go Queen G6
anyway that's true yeah you could try to
run the king I think I think the idea
was that but he didn't go for it and now
black is on the attack insane
look at the time just check and queen
check and queen check again and take on
F5 with the pawn so that you can't take
it back
what is going on in this position
Madness we have two Queens on the board
it's a mad house
yeah Queen H2 good move what a nice move
what a nice finish there it's almost
like your check meeting the attacking
ideas
exactly I see your Checkmate and raise
you Checkmate right like you can't
triple stamp a double stamp Lloyd you
can't triple stamp a double stamp
I see your Checkmate I raise you
Checkmate like what wins right Full
House or straight flush right I mean
half the people at their local poker
game are looking up on their phone
trying not to tip their hand we're like
you don't even know that a straight
flush beats a full house bro never mind
it's just like these are the things and
there you see nerderbeck had that a
clued in for him right he played CD4 and
Bishop B5 again it was just an accident
I think where it was he realized he was
in bullet he was just autopiloting he's
like damn it I didn't play the line I
was supposed to play now he remembered
yep
but he's down a game again Fabiano
caruana has regained his lead
he goes from up four games to down a
game he's back up by one
topsy-turvy is the definition
yeah and I think you know to have this
match be potentially decided by one game
is so fitting but there's still 15 16
minutes of bullet to play which is a lot
of bullet games
a lot of bullet
that's enough for me to get adopted by
one of these guys I would lose 10 games
in a row even to Someone Like You as you
already know so I seem to remember
the point is I am I am living evidence
that a lot of bad things can happen in
15 minutes that's the point okay that's
we don't need to go any further
um
all right Knight to E5 we're back in a
Carlsbad structure probably B5 occurs
soon indeed it does it's on the board
I like White's chances uh here because I
think you can set up and it's just kind
of known that this Knight belongs on D3
it's it's a defensive hero here and
Knight on d39 on D6 maybe that can be
the chat's main takeaway from these
structures yep
these guys always have their pieces
where they want to be E5 an interesting
breakthrough undermining the protection
of the night again it weakens D5 every
time you change the structure but it is
a typical kind of thematic thing to do
mm-hmm
A5 is well kind of hanging now right I I
think it could have been taken and
neither player saw it
Mutual blindness
yeah it was just hanging back to C7 yeah
defended
no I think you were right I think I
think they could have gone for it but
now either way Fabiano to his credit is
up on the clock once again
yeah he's really been been doing that
um and it's been paying dividends for
him it's gonna say I wonder how to
actually get active in this position B4
takes Rook A8 is what he wants
what the heck is this
yeah this doesn't look good for fobby
though because in the end
these pawns are being undermined
and that that night can it stop the past
pawns just take it so or is it free I
was almost for just a half second
thinking of Rook takes C5 I was like
wait a minute it doesn't yeah yeah
okay it doesn't work instead we had
to one of these Rook endings uh it's the
same Rook ending that we had at one
point
um
a little different in terms of the
double pulling structure though
yeah
yeah this uh
I'm not so sure about this by uh my
order back actually yeah
that pass C pawn and Depot and two pass
pawns are usually pretty good
yeah I think the thing at seven was
better than King H6 like if I could
choose where my king is here I'd want it
closer to White spawns but
the white spots are just faster here and
D6 and it's over and Fabiano caruana
I don't want to call it too early but
okay he could this is still blunderable
yeah
but now D7 is Unstoppable
and that'll be all she wrote
yeah the best you can do is play G2 here
but it's not gonna
okay yeah White's gonna pick up the H2
Pawn noterbeck resigns he knows he only
has 12 minutes both players have the
clock in front of them that's right
you know a lot of these games are
following a typical a manometer path
they start out very equal and then you
put that a mon face right where it turns
around and one player gets the advantage
hashtag a monometer
that's okay you can own it it sounds
good it rolls off the tongue well you
know you've heard of The Terminator this
is the amanometer
well Danny there's always that one part
of the show where
feels like you just just go right over
the edge just a little too far and well
there it was no that was that fun
thanks man I appreciate you bringing me
back sometimes I have to cross my own
lines of decency just to remind myself
that I still have lines
then we back up
um and we are in a bishop versus knight
Dynamic but Fabiano really does seem to
have righted the ship which is bad news
for Notre back momentum has turned
squarely the other way around
this night on D4 is quite good but after
C3
the pieces are getting exchanged so I
don't think that Fabi can like play a
knight against Bishop position I'm
expecting Bishop takes E6 because I
don't know if I want to deal with Knight
F4 and bullet
yeah
but apparently he doesn't care I I would
be playing Bishop takes E6 for sure
he waits too long and now now he's gonna
get out with nice C5
is that the idea yeah there's I think we
can just take it yeah you can just take
it back because there's Queen C5 there
and if rookie won there's like I don't
know if it works but you gotta watch out
for things like this right
yeah Queen E2 actually keeps
everything uh amazingly but Queenie two
I think there was following your idea
Knight F4 like a similar plan to get
Rook attacked
yeah agreed now white has kind of routed
around the dysfunction as long as you
unpin the Rook you're you're not worried
anymore about tactics
yeah King G2 and then switch everything
Rook F3 Rook F1 looks like whites kind
of doing well
um
oh yeah here comes H5 F7 is uh
is a weakness maybe just go back for it
obviously if the F7 breaks G6 Falls
yeah just switch the pieces why the heck
not switch to the f file he does it
sometimes it's that simple yeah
you stop this
because remember Queen guards F7 and
there's still Rook F7 Queen G6
yeah
takes everything Fabi runs to h8 has to
be winning for white very nice move
threatens Queen C8 and guards check
although that was already guarded but
seriously great retreating move and I
think it's collected id6 gotta try it
nice
let's just seeing everything take H5
first then you win the Knight Fabiano
resigns interesting match strategy he
doesn't try to get any more time off the
total clock I'm not sure we're in the
territory where it matters I think just
momentum is all that matters right now
I'm on but both players will be aware
that we are under 10 minutes
and uh it's a one game match I think you
need to have like a two-game lead
teetering on three uh before you're
really thinking about that because
remember the way the SEC works and I'm
I'm I've always been a fan of this rule
is that uh the final game as long as it
starts with one two seconds on the match
clock it counts so yeah that's that's
always important for both players but
especially the guy behind to remember
yeah and we've seen it really matter
we've seen epic comebacks that literally
came down to a game that started as
seconds expired so
um
right now and I agree yeah taking taking
extra meta thoughts into consideration
will ruin your ruin the flow right ruin
the Mojo so don't worry about it we're
in a Roy Lopez
um some say don't play the Roy Lopez
against Fabiano Notre Beck says
I got you right here play it every time
yeah every time but Fabiano playing
quickly he is up on the clock every time
they're in the Lopez I will say that
hmm interesting move uh to play B5 maybe
I wasn't sure if he was trying to close
the position with the bishop like on the
inside
you probably should have
probably still can yeah Queen A7 and so
Black's going for like Knight F4 F5 but
it definitely doesn't seem fast enough
Knight G1 is a common idea as well to
try to play G3 here
not every day you see black turn the
momentum toward the king side in the Roy
Lopez but here it is the case you have
to watch out for tactics on H3 already
is they're like dude takes takes takes
age three if you take with the King Rook
takes F3 I don't know if it worked but
there was something nasty going on over
there I say I I see what you're doing
there Queen C8 is almost
yeah basically the same idea of it let's
build it up with a real threat first
Knight G5 covers H3 but how temporary is
Knight G5
yeah it's kicked already and Knight
takes G2 points out we have all kinds of
problems coming in here Queen F3 Knight
H4
wow the computer is like no white is
winning here and I'm scared out of my
mind this is so crazy I would run yeah
King F1 I'm just booking it to the queen
side see you Danny yeah he does it too
Fabiano
cool calm and collected
get out of Dodge run forest run
I think in that position black had to go
Knight F3 check can you two
like yeah something to keep the king
exactly yeah the Knight on F3 would have
guarded D2 everyone so I yeah that was
the key
agreed to read agreed now D6 is gonna
fall
this is not enough
Bobby slipping a little bit
yeah you actually could take D6 there oh
yeah that's a good point because there
was Knight B5 he didn't see it
okay Queen A1 and Knight E1 careful now
this is all 92 92 that's a four five
H5 F4 or something I don't even know I
would go H5
oh now D4 check is on the on the board
and you win the pawn
yeah no
well what a game this is
this is a practical
big moment for Fabi because he's lost
winning advantages under time pressure
already right that's you're thinking the
same thing I am so if he if he doesn't
convert this one that is not a good sign
and it's probably gonna have some
emotional Queenie two I'm the queen
oh my God he just hung the queen you
just hold the queen of one move and
neither player saw it they're just
they're not on the right page but
they're on the same page
they're on the same page like me and you
buddy hey come on look at that and
Fabiano caruana notorbeck shakes off mom
mom was trying to bring him some
lemonade she's like honey you need a
snack no lemonade he's like Mom get away
I'm playing I watch on Twitch I've
actually been noticing that and I the
more I see it the more I'm like no
that's like the the bullet like carpal
tunnel he's like shaking out his wrist
from from moving so damn quick at the
end ah okay it's not Mom not Mom I don't
think so I you know you have your reads
on the Hikaru Nakamura uh you know
Expressions but I I know a good uh
bullet ShakeOut you know when I see him
okay there you go you know a good bullet
shake up when you see it right us old
guys don't play enough bullet to to
resonate with that always thinking like
a dad I want to get my kid a snack when
he's when he's when he's tired
um awesome all right well where are we
at right now we have a two-game lead
four minutes left it has been done
before if notrebec wins this and then
starts the next Game Before Time expires
yeah it's still possible everyone
remembers yonce's stuff dude has come
back versus grishek and like a very
similar position and that's why oh by
the way B4 almost looked like a mouse
slip that's how much I didn't like that
move yeah what whoa okay so weirdly E4
was played and then Knight D2 was kind
of a mini blunder there by white because
Queen D7 forced G4 not a move white
wanted to play
um
yeah but it's weird because B4 didn't
force Knight D2 it just happened to be
played
um yeah he does eventually kind of get
get the pressure over here these pawns
are ugly ducklings
take the bishop Knight C4 B3
yeah he's got to go for the pawn here
has to hey a must-win game for
norderbeck the reason why you and I
aren't panicking about the two-game lead
is because hey this is the game that
matters the most no matter what uh it's
a must win for white and if he does win
it we're gonna have such an epic finish
such an epic match I mean I'm not gonna
lie I'm rooting for Notre back in this
game because I want more chess and if
Bobby wins it's over so let's go Notre
Beck
um he's gotta win right here right now
yep
but Fabi this is starting to I mean from
a practical perspective black has got
the H file D4 was a very nice move
though it really was
um yeah I was gonna say you almost have
to play F6 but
um instead he threatens me and now Queen
takes E5 he cannot dislodge that Knight
easily you need oh it goes for the queen
trade smart actually very smart yeah get
the Queens off
you're up a pawn if you're white I can
see four control
yep
all right that's not a bad idea but
fobby says I'm all right I'm gonna I'm
gonna keep that night right where he
belongs yeah but now there's a Pawn on
G5 you can go back to Rook E3 and then
play Knight C4
yeah
better a5's hanging oops
C4 A5 lots of things hanging
not a lot of time big practical problem
like allowing A4 A3 is just I don't
think you want to do it but I have to
doesn't say anything better
and uh
this is this is a position you could
lose with one move you you step wrong
and you miscalculate and here comes that
night guess what he has to try Danny so
I don't blame him at all motor those
pawns off the board and leave The Rook
on A1 just go go go yep yep yep agreed
here he goes he's playing it well he has
to win this game or the match is over
King back to E4 check
play C4 what's the move
D1
yeah this is how this is too much
that's gonna be it he's still got a
position here but yeah this is uh
impossible no that's it right there
yep that is going to be the match
it would have been enough time for one
more game Danny but
oh my gosh one move the eval bar reveals
Fabiano plays Rook D1 and it's over no
matter what happens I'm now I mean the
the time is running out at this point
and all Fabi has to do is run out the
clock yeah the thing is he can draw the
game that's why there's not really exact
pressure because even a draw here is
enough
yeah that was my that was my point well
said you often say things better another
reason you're a grand master you know
um but wow so tough for nordeback who
played such a phenomenal match and
really gave himself chances in this
final game too
yep yep yep and just like that Fabiano
caruana holds on by the several hairs on
his chinny chin chin in fact it's a
mustache if you look closely it's right
there
um and uh we have one more player moving
on to the round of eight he smiles he
grabs a drink of water he's like bring
on Hikaru I got you boy right here bring
on Hikaru
he's not sure how to feel that's a sigh
of relief maybe disgust with some of his
own moves this match but also hey of
course he's happy to get the win and
what what a thrilling match uh Danny
because although the final score
actually opened up to a three-point
Victory it was truly a 1.1 game match
the entire way
yeah
wow indeed I agree with everything you
said it was way closer than a three-game
score a three-game score is not a bad
not a bad match we all had a great time
here today sticking around we have
interviews we have Savvy moves we have a
lot of Chess ahead here on the show so
don't leave just yet but but it was even
closer than three games a month and if
you're Notre back I know a loss doesn't
feel good but the kid just continues to
show that he's uh he's gonna be the name
for many years to come
absolutely I mean what what a match uh I
think this was the match that everyone
expected it to be at times it looked
like oh maybe someone might run away
with it oh nordeback is right back in it
but in the end it truly was decided by
that single game there at the end
chances missed by both sides looking
back on the on the games I'm sure
they'll both be like oh I I should have
had this I shouldn't have done that but
ultimately this was just the close fight
that we all signed up for
yeah they delivered as they say and we
are going to deliver with more content
ahead as I said we have interviews we
have Savvy moves to break down we have
more from them on Hamilton don't go
anywhere the 2023 speeches Championship
presented by coinbase final moments of
the day when we returned
foreign
spells jump or freeze let's start with
two jump spells and five free spells
which we charge after five moves you may
cast your spare whenever you wish before
making a regular chest move jump is a
spell cast to one square wherein if
there is a piece on that square other
pieces can jump over the Charmed piece
the freeze spell is cast over a three by
three square area and the pieces in this
area are temporarily Frozen in place
and bang your powers of Chess and
sorcery to defeat your opponent
see what supercell and chess.com have
cooked up in our new variant spell chess
dropping on September 1st
hey
what's up
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
Ed by Fabiano caruana the 2023 speeches
Championship presented by coin boys had
coinbase had yet another great match
Bobby I get accused of bias towards you
A lot and I'm not going to apologize for
our friendship but I just want to own up
I was rooting for Notre back in that
last game because I wanted more chess
between you guys this was an awesome
match you did get the job done your your
initial thoughts
yeah I I was not hoping for him to win
the last game because uh although I like
entertaining matches
it's also incredibly stressful to be
sitting here playing one minute chess
and any mistake can cost you the match
it was really tough
um at some point I felt very good in the
match I thought I was basically running
away with it but then I started to choke
game after game
uh losing positions I had no business
losing
and um yeah it was one of those typical
matches of momentum in some ways he I
clearly had it at some point early on in
the match and then he clearly had it
going into the bullet
but somehow I managed to uh to get some
very important points near the end of
the match
yeah
I think that's a great point you talk
about momentum I was actually going to
highlight it felt like you lost the game
on time in what should have been just a
dead draw and that kind of started the
momentum in a bad way against you I'm I
feel like I know you well enough so I'm
gonna ask you Fabi were you on tilt man
somewhat but I I'm kind of used to these
matches I have kind of maybe not a huge
amount of experience but a decent amount
of experience because they've been going
on for the speeches Championship has
been going on for so many years so I I
realized at some point that it always
comes down to the last few games okay
there there are some like runaway
matches that that happened and I've been
on the receiving end unfortunately a few
times but but most of the time it comes
down to the final three games even if
someone builds up a very big lead early
on like there was the Levon against
Wesley match which was like a seven
point lead and then if only a few things
had gone differently for Levon in the
bullet I think that he would have uh it
would have been really really close so
even these matches where one player
seems to have a huge lead they very
often come down to the last few games so
I realized that
you know if I didn't
um completely tilt then maybe uh and if
I play well in bullet then I would
probably have chances even if I'm
trailing at some point
it's great stuff you know one of the
things we highlighted about the two of
you heading into this match is that you
had 232 games in the SEC
notorbeck had 55 and we talked about
experience
if if I'm replaying some of the things
the modern I talked about he kept going
into this Catalan line where you were
super comfortable with the opposite code
Bishop compensation maybe you prepared
that for this match I don't know but it
was working out and then we were
critical of notorbeck's choice to play
the alkyne in the early portions of the
3-1 almost like he was getting a little
bit too crazy unnecessarily so right the
match was still close and let me just
ask you like do you feel like some of
his inexperience and some of those
choices going for that opening in the
Catalan maybe playing the alkyne
ultimately hurt him in a very close
match
I'm not sure if it's an experience I I
think that like we've played quite a few
matches online and and we have some
experience over the board as well where
he does tend to Target me in the cat
alone and usually quite successfully and
I don't think it was a bad choice
necessarily because
I I couldn't remember exactly how to
play this line
and it did result in some bad positions
and and also I did lose this very
critical game in the three minute where
he he made it me and also I blundered
the D5 plug which you didn't notice in
the opening but
but yeah so I don't think that it was a
bad choice he just tended to
um drift in these obsequently Bishop
positions from what I was I was seeing
like I had I really shouldn't have won
that position where I'm in a slightly
worse end game I mean it just you you
should never win that so uh and likewise
for that obstacle bishop and game we got
from the Italian like there was a theme
for let's say the early to mid portion
of the match where we were playing an
enormous amount of optical or pen
games and I was getting the better of it
most of the time so
I don't know if that's really experience
or bad opening choice I mean it could
have also gone the other way that he was
out playing me
um
you know it's easy in hindsight right
it's easy to say I should have done this
differently or I should have done this
better but we're very often taking
decisions in real time
and and yeah they could be questionable
or they could work out perfectly and you
look like a genius it's uh it's one of
those things that you can't really know
for sure in the moment
yeah yeah I was actually gonna ask kind
of about looking back in hindsight there
was a very clear dynamic between you two
where nordebec would get quite low on
time and I feel like early on in the
match there was a noticeable game where
you kind of over pressed in his time
pressure and he flipped it around in one
but then later on you also used his time
pressure against him effectively was
that a struggle that you were kind of
noticing in many of the games that he
would get low on time you could try to
use it against him
yeah I wasn't at all surprised that I
would like I kind of expected that I
would get the lead on the clock early on
in the games and then he would um
usually outplay me once once we get down
to seconds because I'm not really very
consistent or I it's not like I'm
terrible but I'm not very consistent
when it comes down to the final few
seconds sometimes I can
um like scrape my way out of trouble but
purely by luck it's not like I have the
skill that let's say uh Hikaru or or
Magnus or alireza have where they can
play very very well even
um even when they're down to like two
seconds for me the main task is just not
to flag like that's that's already an
accomplishment uh in itself
so so I wasn't surprised that in that
when we're getting down to a few seconds
that I I was struggling especially early
on because you know I haven't played
this um like this format in a year so uh
early on the match I expected a little
bit of rust when it comes down to when
it came down to the last few seconds
well well honestly I feel like I want to
kind of unpack a lot about your thought
process in this match especially given
the momentum that it was and lucky for
us we've got more great questions here
courtesy a feature chat uh so back to
the momentum
this one's from nightwind Archer one
wanted to talk about how you stayed calm
after having blown that lead right you
lost five games in a row and you were
just losing uh you weren't just not
leading anymore you were losing so what
was going through your thought process
at that time for our for our chatter
here
yeah I did have some uh
some negative thoughts let's say they do
tend to creep in when you're spoiling
things especially when I have a very big
lead and I could have extended it so I I
had those intrusive thoughts coming in
and then I we had a break like I guess
it was about an eight minute break I
went out on the balcony I just tried to
not think about the match for for a few
minutes uh and then the first game the
first bullet game was such a mess I mean
I I was I was losing I was winning and
then suddenly I I
lost in the last few seconds and after
that I was very jittery I thought this
was the most dangerous moment in the
match for sure
um like also when you get down to these
top scrambles and also that they don't
work out it gets you very nervous so I
was very nervous at this moment and and
also trailing that was probably the
worst moment in the match for me but but
things kind of went well after that I I
I I didn't expect it to go so well
um but it was even a comfortable lead
coming into end of course I could have
lost the last game but already he was
coming up on uh time running out in the
entire match so yeah but that that was
indeed a very difficult moment
psychologically
well Fabi I uh I don't mean to uh look
ahead too far into the future in this
tournament but our chatter here is soy
Chente is wondering how you're gonna
plan for your next match against Hikaru
yeah well Hikaru is about as tough and
upon an opponent as you can get
I mean he won last year and he's
basically always gotten to the final I
think that that's true like every
Edition he's gotten to the final of this
so yeah that's that's a very tough match
I I won't um I won't sugarcoat it but uh
I'm glad that I got past the first one
I I just did play a tournament with the
car we played the um the Fisher random
event and last night we were kind of
hanging out a big group of people
and uh he was playing bullet Hikaru was
against Rey
um but it was it was like 35 seconds
against one minute it was very fast
bullet and over the board you
um you basically shouldn't be able to
play with 35 seconds right you should be
getting flagged every single game but
his skills are quite incredible even
over the board in in this um
like in terms of bullet I I mean he he
really is a monster
um but okay I'll do my best I uh you
know I have a long history with Hikaru
going back uh more than a decade of
professional trusts at the top level
um so I I don't know if it'll be a
pleasure to play him again but uh
uh but hopefully it'll be a good match
and hopefully I'll fight well
it's mind-blowing by the way 35 seconds
to one minute no TV bullets sorry we'll
unpack that later but all right another
question from Chad to unpack this
comebacks this comes to us from the
unpaid debt
um let's hope he's taking care of that
unpaid debt uh he wants you to give us
Insight on how Grandmasters like
yourself stay calm spot tactics and your
opponent's blunders when under time
pressure
I think a lot of it really is Instinct
it's not something that you can
necessarily learn because when you're
making these like Split Second decisions
you can't
see much of anything I mean you're very
much relying on Instinct and a few
tactics in the position so um yeah I I
some people's tactical vision is better
than others some people's intuition is
better than others but
um but it's not something that there's
like
some some clear advice I can give
uh I do have to say that one of the main
strengths I think of these like really
great players who play very well under
under their last few seconds is that
they they do manage to stay calm they
are not panicking
and um
and that's that's a skill in itself that
you can actually stay calm when you're
when you're close to flagging so some
people are really good at that
um some I'm naturally very good at that
for example car of course he's he stays
calm Ali Reza is also a very good
example
um and some are less good but it is
definitely a very important skill to
have
well Fabi we appreciate your time I've
got one more question for you from our
chatter jayegon who basically wondering
what honestly a lot of us would like to
know how is the SCC for you I mean you
compete at the highest level in your OTB
tournaments but how is it to play the
speed Chess Championship is it more
stressful do you enjoy it more are you
more liberal with some of the variations
you're willing to try uh what do you
think of the event
well it's it's definitely very stressful
because we're getting down to the last
few seconds and you have all that
adrenaline and things happening so
quickly uh of course there's there's
less at stake compared to let's say you
know uh the candidates or or the World
Cup or something like that so the stress
is
um is contained to a very short period
of time let's say a few hours and and
like all chess tournaments events and
I'm sure everyone can relate to this
um it's very fun if you win and it's
very not fun if you don't like it so I
think everyone has everyone knows that
feeling of the disappointment of of uh
losing a critical game and the joy of a
playing great or winning an important
game or tournament or or whatever you
know your goal is
um but I do enjoy it that's why I play
every year because I I do like this um
this format and I like
um playing against the best players in
the world in a very competitive and
unique
um sort of event like this
well Bobby this has been great we can't
wait to see what happens in your next
match with Hikaru but I'm gonna bring
our interview to a close here by giving
you a chance while you control the
microphone uh to state your case for why
your cat deserves a bot the next time we
bring the cat Bots back you have 30
seconds Sir bringing the DMS from you
and Lavon aronian attacking me into the
into the fold
foreign
's dog has a butt and I'm absolutely
sure that levon's dog is much weaker
than my cat at chess I don't even think
it's okay so I think that that alone is
enough of an argument
um but also my cat is extremely good
looking a very handsome boy okay and I
think he deserves to be seen by all
chess lovers and chess players in the
world
all right that was pretty good I'm not
gonna lie um I don't make all the oh
yeah I don't make all the decisions
around here just.com despite um what uh
they would tell you um but we will I
will do my best to get to get the catbot
into the Forefront along with ponchek um
so all right man good to see you enjoy
the evening enjoy the Victory and uh
good luck in the next round congrats
Fabian
thanks guys thanks for having me
all right I'm on that was Mr car you
wanna Fabiano
Fabio no cariano
you didn't have the guts to do that
while he was you're on the air with us
did you
heard me heard me but there you go he
moves on in a thriller over abduces her
off what a day we've had together man
seriously this was awesome uh and uh he
takes on Nakamura in the Next Room that
because as he alluded to is no uh not
not everyone's favorite pairing but
guess what Naka has made it to the
finals of this event uh pretty much
every single time he wins it most of the
time as well so that's a tough opponent
no matter who you are and Bobby he
called a spade a spade he said you know
what it's never easy to play Hikaru but
he's gonna give it his best shot and
hopefully he can uh you know fight well
as he said
agreed and I don't know what he would
consider success there I don't I mean if
he considers himself a big enough
Underdog that he doesn't expect to win
he just wants to have a lead going into
bullet I don't know but it's going to be
a really interesting one to the top
Americans in history throwing down in
the round of eight but all right we have
to throw down with our last content of
the day it's time for The coinbase Savvy
move I think there were a lot of Savvy
moves in this match among by both
players but you chose one from that game
where where Fabiano said uh let's not
bring the alkyne anymore in my house
right Fabiano took care of business and
show us how he finished the job here in
this alkyne's defense yeah and the fans
will remember this was uh potentially
nordeback a little bit on tilt who knows
um and you know Fabi mentioned it in the
interview there but after Queen to d8 in
this position Abby wasted no time I have
to admit I was thinking about slow moose
Bishop F4 maybe Pawn to F4 but to my
surprise and very much in the spirit of
the position and the way that he was
putting on pressure this match Pawn to
G5 was played here by Fabi and the
reason that I found this move to be so
fitting for this segment Danny was I
think that it is the definition of Savvy
G5 comes with that that poison Knight to
F6 is a threat here if you take the pawn
the bishop takes back and you've got the
same exact threat building up so just as
a tough move to react to I thought G5
was literally the definition of Savvy
and it worked out Danny as you can see
what nordeback played here yeah and I
don't think it's fair to to stress about
the myths from the uh from the the
computer's perspective this is a move
you play when your opponent has only
five seconds on the clock and the
tactics by themselves are gonna blow him
off the board and so he plays G5 with
the threat of Knight F6 check notabeck
doesn't see it or stop it blunders
directly into the discovery even if
Knight F6 check alone was that was The
Savvy finish I agree with you that G5
sets it up and that's exactly the kind
of thing you do when you're bringing a
game to a close that your opponent is is
under pressure and and under pressure on
the clock so G5 Knight F6 check that was
it the Savvy move brought to you by
coinbase and uh and that's how Fabiano
beat the alakai we didn't see it again
so even though father didn't necessarily
agree with me that uh Notre Beck had
some inexperience definitely agreed on
the board that it wasn't a good idea to
play this again and car wanna got the
job done today
it's true like he literally he beat the
opening out of the match it never came
back so uh pretty pretty well done there
by Fabby always nice to hear his
thoughts as well always said I think
fabby's a great interview
um you know spending his time with us
after a long match like that so it's
interesting to hear his perspective but
what a what a deserved win and winner um
and not to take anything away from
Dorter back who really played a great
match and as I keep reminding people it
came down to really the last game as fat
he alluded to an interview
it was thrilling a greed Town population
us were still living there between the
U.S and Canada let's talk about where
we're going to be living tomorrow
because I don't know if people uh know
this yet but you know tomorrow's a
double header oh yeah yes indeed we have
mvl versus gookash we have Magnus
Carlson making his debut this year
against vidit Gujarati uh I don't even
know what anyone else is doing tomorrow
it's time to call in sick right now we
got a devil header of the SEC
I mean that's That's so exciting you
have two incredible talents from India
that are up against uh some of the best
players in the world uh how about the
actual best players in the world Magnus
Carlson seeing him in the SEC uh it's
kind of gonna be a you know a reminder
to people when they see Magnus in the
SEC they're like oh yeah that's right
that potential matchup Hikaru Magnus
Brewing once again so I think people
will be excited for that team agreed
agreed agreed agreed with so much today
I feel like this show brought us all
closer brought us closer with chat
brought our relationship closer and you
know what else brings people closer
together
tell me Danny tell me the Judith Polgar
Global chess Festival the hashtag chess
connects us all that's right and this
year we are calling all chess clubs who
are eligible to participate in the
Judith Polgar chess connects us
Championship it's a challenge for all
clubs you can nominate four players to
compete in the online event on October
14th a chance to win prizes from
chess.com from chessable from Judith
Polgar herself join us in celebrating
the game that brings us all together and
again use the command chess connects in
chat to learn more
um just does connect us you know Justice
for everyone chess brings us all
together I'm on it brings all the
differences
between you and I just it it brings them
out and then also gets rid of them so
that in the end of the day we're just
closer that's right Danny and shout out
to Judith just the incredible person
player commentator does so much for
chess so that's awesome
indeed it was awesome shout out to the
whole team working hard today was
awesome awesome chess by our players
carwana and abdusa turov awesome show by
our production crew our mods our team
working hard behind the scenes thank you
so much for my partner Amon Hamilton his
name is Oman Hamilton he is the chess
bro I'm on Hamilton and there's a
million things he hasn't done so just
you wait we're out of here everybody see
you tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]